[Music]
a
n
[Music]
come
on come
[Music]
on
n
[Music]
yes
sir what's going on real how you doing
little tired little tired go my
check I see yall up in here I see in
here see a lot of people up in here
already early on the Lord's day
Sunday going on Allen what's up Z ask
King
my thank you brother sounds good you
know what I'm
saying be to go I appreciate yo shout
out to y'all thanks for the
love last week your
situation kind of fortunate about
right for those who were complaining
about what the hell was that beeping
sound during the petore interview now
yall know I'll playing later but thanks
for the love I appreciate could have
been a different
situation
Sunday I know I know what yall
here I know what yall here I see y'all
in here early b
see what's going on okay you okay I see
you Lord days Upon Us Zach Riley what's
going on L Master what's up Mason Allen
Doctor Strange Love we definitely making
it a pause cast a
lot pop out what's up Jo M the OG Bay
Area what's going on good to see you
shout out to the chat good to see
everybody to see y'all too Jason James
Morrison Isaac Hayes 85 what's going on
what's up lis cyer Sao I like that
what's going on Lord Brown what's up
slack
John you die harder you die harder you
know what I'm saying No Doubt no doubt
Regina oh she's going miss this live
okay yeah King going be on you already
know what you already know what is is
Young the artist was going on levels a
little low I know I'm I'm I'm a little
let me check
um I know I'm
talking
it is that a little better is that a
little better still low I know I'm
talkinging okay okay holding
[Music]
line Black Lightning what's going on
some Lo all right Dre finishing up the
work okay finishing up the work still a
bit low it could be the baross it could
be the baross um when we go through the
show let me know I think cuz we got the
music in the p
it is what it
is oh I see y'all on that slander I see
yall on that slander that's what's up no
doubt so yeah we going to get the rest
of the Lords up in here yeah we holding
it we holding it and yeah it should be
fun it should be fun you're not it's
going to be a main topic that I know
y'all want someone to get their bars
off we's see how that go and uh yeah I'm
looking forward to we got a lot of topic
we got a lot of catching up to do it's
going to be good let me go get the rest
of the Lord I don't know where everybody
I smoke the king but I got to see what's
going on with um with addict and saw
probably you know long night you know
there was a fight last night too any I
will talk to y'all we going get y These
Bars from Dallas see in a
minute here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that want to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beat and they
want to compare me to Freddy and Jason I
rather be Hannibal they be like why use
a video game just be original y'all to
Dramatical I know it's random but I am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
aring up in your partment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting and range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on a check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got let's switch that what did
you do Don't Stop N that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel them to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault TR with a gang of
cougar and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is De Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Saron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but antisocial love my city but
I'm still by coal I got let's Swit that
up what did you do stop that wase that
keep that going keep that going no go
ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoal feel to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you ain't got to
say I'm embarrassed for you always been
a nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' to messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating rappers but that's all a part of
me being aable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I
got's what did you do don't stop that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled feel to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vultron with a gang of cougers and I'm
going places better tell a uber because
it's pretty hard to sleep on friend KRW
that's let's do that again
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be handable
they be like why use a video gang just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they it's sarson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the r you just a Target when
I'm in the range I was the hardest to
start regardless back we was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals I on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got Swit what
you do stop that was keep keep that keep
that going keep that going go ahead look
I guess you could say that I'm very
spoal feel them to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making INF flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sson up in the apartment
they call it Department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I got let's Swit
that stop that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vult Tron with a gang of coug and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so uh
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that y fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rign you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on a check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still by coal I
Gott what did you doing don't stop that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go Ahad look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoal
feel them to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boyal you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
krger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making INF flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still I got let's
[Music]
Swit keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoiled to be your dog
thing very but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't here the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser makeing
vron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a u because
it's pretty hard to sleep on Fredy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eat these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be your original y'all to Dramatical I
know it's random but I addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got Swit
what did you doing Don't Stop N that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoal feel
them to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am
um what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lord's podcast
right now as we speak and uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heades be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being account accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by Cal I got let's switch
that up you do Don't Stop N that was Doe
keep that keep that keep that going keep
that going n Go ahead look I guess you
can say that I'm very SPO to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep I'm Freddy
crw good
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video
[Music]
game
call all cloud and clear a proclamation
of invitation turn not on
me I C the
ofal the River St Lawrence with a water
St through what us
and I'mma just chill and watch them and
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then they will mistake me for attic
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give her that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get tossed
in the bushes by King David royalty and
not a pretender detrimental to a
Elemental was a avatar to a KNE Bender I
got to be me though I know it's my
destiny work kindo who cares if you fly
if you still a mosquito you swear you
ain't something but really be steo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that dude King still be the king of
the statue since a juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we meet in The Crucible
other than that it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday is suitable cuz you can
listen to this and your cubicle on the
Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday a
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a Lord's
[Music]
Day right out the tunnel like yeah son
so how did you feel about getting leap
yeah then you be see they really not
prepared to professionally talk but they
got to and I I just always love that ADV
anyway we we Mike's alive we uh going
mike check right quick just make sure
they hear y'all cuz I can see my you
doing how you do yeah yeah what up what
up hello hello hello yeah yeah no doubt
all right switching over right here ye
hear ye and we are live and welcome to
the iron Lords podcast LLC and also live
on Lords of gaming.net episode number
324 it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
date and today we've got Jim Ryan
leaving
PlayStation
cyberpunk Phantom Liberty Redemption Arc
Xbox Tokyo game show and Quest 3 with
Game Pass to discuss so we going to get
right into it so let's introduce we are
missing a Horseman where is this can
anyone find this where's this one this
this this Horseman here we we got to
find this one anybody knows what was it
it's 10:00 where are your
children clock where are y'all children
Lord addict this one is missing
definitely not back to back he is he is
not back to back he's the chair is
spinning somewhere if anyone can find
out the whereabouts of Lord addict from
IOP we greatly appreciate it but anyway
hopefully our brother is okay what's up
py I see you in the chat I don't know
where this boy is at but uh now
hopefully he's okay all jokes aside but
uh you know we still got the other horse
in the realm and of course our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the srad damus the
Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of the
iron bank PC Master Race's own show us
your build how you doing sir I'm doing
I'm doing all right I'm dry I
who dry weekend W cuz I saw um what's
his name Super Chat last week did you
I don't know I missed that I don't
recall that oh I I I saw it in the OBS
and it was it was he was talking about
your throat and the condition and how he
can help oh my goodness yeah you were
going through things he was trying to
offer services but anyway moving on how
are you
doing bro I saw that Super Chat cuz
remember I ran out cu my situation so
I'm seeing the super chats that would
came through I was like yo that's wow
but anyway as a matter of fact yeah I'm
going to try to figure out I'm going to
go back to last week's stream and try to
get as many as I can I cuz I never copy
paste them anymore because we have the
fan funding and uh but for older ones
for for previous ones it doesn't come up
as fan funding so I have to kind of
scroll through it so I'll try to get as
many as I can um but yeah um yeah
dealing with water situations all
weekend um it's been it's been kind of
crazy for me cuz as you know like in
mile on of work it it's just just water
everywhere you had to get the vacuum
pump you had to pump had dealing with
and know and it's not just flood water
right was like oh let's let's have this
let's have this pipe burst let's have
this pipe burst and sewage and yeah yeah
not good not good so it's been it's been
that kind of weekend but um I did you
know the the benefit of that is while
you're waiting for things to dry you can
throw on the r
app Microsoft
hand the new Microsoft handh R Ally the
real handheld and I finished I finished
the the uh Mortal Kombat one story b
o let's get it and it's I like it I mean
I like it to me there were Parts towards
the end that I like it felt like it
jumped real quick to like the end part
like it was the part where it was like
okay let's gather The
Avengers all right here we are so it was
it jumped but it was it was very cool
and then it creates a scenario where
obviously they can go kind of anywhere
that they want with it um afterwards but
it was it's it's very good um especially
for a story mode or F you had a caveat
with that but it is you know it is a
fighting game story mode so everything
everything funnels you towards a
one-on-one fight right um but that that
game looks beautiful oh my God plays
beautifully the uh after after you
finish the story mode and I got into the
invasions I was like okay now I can
finally do fatalities and stuff like
that and seeing these wild fatalities
and Jesus CHR the guys have too much
time on their
hand ality guy on that team there we go
yeah so it was it was fun so yeah now
I'm going to try to kind of hone up my
my versus skills and see see how I do in
that regard but it great game great game
and excited to be getting into oh and
then I also I booted up AC Brotherhood
again because I wanted to get a feel for
old AC again before Mirage dropped um
and yeah so that it's been cool going
back to that cuz Etso is my favorite
assassin um so to see go back to Etso
and and and doing it kind of on the PC
so you know it it it looks nicer and
runs better than it did on the
360 yes yes yes that's what's up pretty
much it yeah it's pretty much been it no
doubt quickly uh shout out to fans uh
condolences to him and his family um
well I there's a there's a gofund me I
put that in the chat but uh yeah us you
know his dad passed away uh condolences
yeah sorry sorry I spoke I spoke to him
I spoke to him maybe two days ago and
dad was was still fighting cuz it wasn't
looking good but he was still fighting
and then I saw the post so yeah
definitely uh let's send some love to
our brother fans gaming J foni
absolutely you know what I mean that's
the homie right there and um I know he's
going through it right now so please
send some love we'll put the uh
information for the go from me because I
think it's Dad's wishes for to to to
have a a burial Proper Burial in the
service yep absolutely cool cool that's
been it sir for you yes sir that is it
no doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer oo the prophet of Xbox swamy King
of the statues who demands nothing less
the that premium experience and is the
leader of the whole theine movement oo
beloved Lord King how we doing sir I'm
doing better than Jim
is Jim
I'm G to have fun
today we're going to call you into the
office today but no I G to give a shout
out to uh Canelo um this was the best
shape I've seen him look in the last
three to four years be honest with you
yeah yeah yeah um he had something to
prove he's his own self
motivator and if people doubt him he's
driven to prove them wrong so um he went
out there and he fought Charlo they're
both the same age Charlo is taller
Charlo has a longer reach and Charlo was
coming up two weight classes to fight
him yeah yeah that's no excuse I don't I
don't care that's no excuse uh you take
the challenge if you you to you dare to
be great facts he D to be great so what
I can say to Charlo is Canelo hit you
with something or was doing something
that stopped you from your offense and
stopped you from being yous the only
time you would lose in the ring is when
you can't impose your strategy mhm and
you didn't impose your strategy at the
end you said well he didn't knock me out
yeah I a like that kid I'm
like it's better to go out on your
Shield than to purposely try to go 12
rounds just to say you didn't knock me
out though like that there's no points
there you're telling everybody there
that you didn't give 100% yeah you
basically said your goal was not to win
the
fight I'm going out there and if if if I
happen to
win then it happens if he slips on a
banana pill but I'm like ugas please
retire o I saw that too you got beat
from Pillar To
Post from a fighter that came from
135 yikes and your face was swollen you
were catching punches you wasn't
delivering your timing was off it's like
you and Spence went through the same
time war that fight that you and Spence
hads took a lot out of both of you yeah
because both of you do not look the same
so um brother I will tell you to retire
right now because you're going to get
hurt you had two retina surgeries one in
each of your
eyes so that's completely D dangerous
ericon
Luben
you was the surprise of the evening okay
I thought Ramos was gonna beat the
brakes off you and you went in there and
you you fought a discipline fight you
gave great offense when you needed to
and you took that crowd out of the fight
it was a great fight um finally you know
you got a chance to become a champion in
this division so my hats off to you um
what I've been playing what you been
playing H what is that um cyber Punk
yeah check that out um playing a little
bit of
Forza uh fortnite of course of of course
of course
and um something else I'mma show them
oh something else you know nice things
nice things we G talk about that later
no doubt for a treat looks like uh we
found our missing child
oh it's 1 p.m. we now know where our
children
are Lord addict is that you sir see your
Zoom is muted but he seems to exist so
we we hopefully we'll get his voice soon
but he is in the building we think all
right well we'll see we he could be
traveling so anyway we we'll talk to him
when he's got his situation together and
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito spread
that real in the r the IOP not tell you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear yo shout out to everybody um
last week first of all apologies
obviously on the stream you know but
shout out to everybody who really hit me
up and just wanted to you know check see
if I was all right
um I now know what a carbon monoxide uh
alarm sounds like and for those who are
complaining during a petore interview it
was you know again the rec brief recap
you know I just thought it was a smoke
alarm I was panicking cuz I'm like what
is this beeping while Peter's talking
and you know chat was giving me crap so
I just ran into the bedroom the source
of it and I'm like oh okay in my mind yo
this is just a battery yelling that it
needs to be whatever move it to the
living room all right come back let's
listen to Peter let's listen to Peter
beeping still aggressively loud and I'm
like all right now I'm going move you to
the other side of the apartment lock you
with a bre shut up Peter talking we got
to this thing trying to save my life I'm
in there trying to silence an aggressive
you know carbon monoxide alarm so you
know yeah come you did order the thing
that I said yeah you know I know yeah me
and you talked and I I got the new new
with a joint that be like yo it's the
it's the it's the death the death is
here in in the room in the bedro room
left quadrant the death is here so what
happened is I'm trying I'm trying to
silence this thing saving me and then
while the podcast is going on I'm
getting my phone's blowing up I'm I
don't answer no unknown numbers during
the podcast we don't do that over here
you know what I'm saying professional
podcast yeah I'm like we a doing that
then the the my my bell is buzzing I'm
like Amazon FedEx we ain't doing that no
you then I get a text that's like yo are
you
alive I'm apartment such and such and
we've evacuated the building so I'm like
what what's going on so I'm sitting
there like and I'm trying to get lucky
at this point now Peter is pretty much
gone and we're doing I think s you were
you save me because you was doing like
super chats and you and K had a good
discussion and you got right you got up
for a minute right yeah you if you
notice I keep getting up so then what
happens is um I Hadar somebody trying to
get in the joint so I'm like hold on we
not we not hold on we not doing that
hold on so I so I go to I thought they
was coming I was like yo you hear
somebody opening trying to open your
door to your place it's problems now now
we got to go handle to handle so I go
over there and there's a dude with a
mask and he's holding like this meter
and he's like dangerous carbon monoxide
get out of the apartment he's it's the
gas person in the fire department and
I'm like oh oh we got to go so that's
what I came back I'm like y we out we
out in the Stream in the Stream right so
that's what happened so basically you
know they evacuated um I was out of the
apartment for a few hours I went and got
something to eat came back they found
the source of the leak the only thing
that sucked was like no heat and no hot
water for for a couple couple days until
they really got to the source but
thankfully I am okay you know what I'm
saying and um yeah it was just a scary
situation but shout out to King put me
on you know what I'm saying as far as
getting if you would have went to sleep
yeah with that situation it's over it's
over and literally if you had continued
and you hadn't any sort of warning you
would have passed out on stream that's
what he said he they they told me the
fight he said bro he said the um the the
gas guy was like yo you lucky you didn't
pass out that's the first thing he said
cuz he was like the levels was so crazy
so I had to air to join out leave and
then once they they came back later on
they checked the levels in the apartment
make sure we then I ordered to join King
told me and whatever whatever but yeah I
did get myself checked out make sure I
was okay and that was that yeah what's
up what's up again oh God he said give
him a second okay cool no doubt no doubt
but anyway so that was that uh shout out
to Mr mat play Shout out to finding Duke
talking all Xbox news go check that out
shout out to last wordy Bond we had my
man um no time TR no Travis this week
shout out to Travis he's been super busy
but we had um film star martial artarts
stuntman my man IRL Guardian James
Newman really dope episode talking about
martial arts all the films and stuff
he's doing it's been cool um games I've
been playing obviously you know um cyber
Punk obviously we're going to talk about
that the Phantom Liberty DLC oh shout
out shout out to party animals yo I I I
played it and I ain't going front like
it is the most hilarious joint all right
they y to work y got to work on your
control and y'all little Bare Bones on
the mes but the difference of why I love
it versus a four guys off is it's about
the straight violence you can fight
about the straight it's not about just
trying to find a platform to stand on
and it's like punch him and they got the
best lean and out cute animals that like
they eyes go black and they get
stretched like it is the F and they
tumble everybody run like they drunk
right they got the drunk
run bro it is the most hilarious thing
like I'm literally laughing out loud
every time I play it so yeah salute to
them hopefully they add more features
more modes they got like a a regular
like you know kind of King in the hill
joint but they they got objective kind
of mode stuff like that so shout out to
party animals I do like we got to do a
stream with that that's going to be
really fun and then um yeah still doing
U you know obviously my star Starfield
New Game Plus finishing up certain
faction Quest having still a lot of fun
with that game and doing my achievement
cleanup but uh yeah that's been pretty
much it for me and don't know if adct is
still back he must be in the bush he's
muted still so I'm going to wait for his
camera to come on before we talk to him
but uh s you want to get the super chat
how you what you want to do yeah that's
good uh yeah let's get super chats let's
do that let's do that let's get the the
ones we have so far and then I'll try to
get some of the ones from last week um
we got fors a legend member for 45
months Lord bronze King is the god of
Xbox on God and M he literally has Xbox
vision is Xbox Vision that is the true
leader of
Xbox K King it's time for buck to give
Jim that
work
no absolutely not then let's put the
crust in the chat for God Emperor
Emperor so King and gifted five IOP
memberships thank you appreciate that
then we got BT Maverick 707 $10 Super
Chat General King we've captured Sony's
mascots and forced their leader Jim Ryan
into hiding in quadruple Game Pass in
their Homeland and the armies of the ABK
will be gathering with us soon what's
next
king waiting for orders sir
Savage then we have Doctor Strange Love
$5 Super Chat oh boy since today is a
special day for King I'm going to give
him a sweet
treat a nice long creamy banana sundae
with a hefty load of truffle butter
onp back to you so you with that truffle
but you with that truffle son nothing
nothing like that
sorry we refuse your gift
here
yo
K here we got jfx 885 Super Chat baby
steps is a reenactment of how Sony tried
to march on us and failed when the
Beloved King told us Hold the Line Ding
Dong The Wicked Jim is dead wow wow we
doing that baby steps is Jim
leaving take steps hilarious then we got
God Emperor Sofa King again put the
crest in the chat gifted five more IOP
memberships appreciate that salute and
we got BT Maverick 707 once again $2
Super Chat don't sleep on cocoon
freaking great indie game yes I heard
that
heard then we have that lazy otaku
member for two months Lord bronze Phil
dominous Maximus murderous aelia
Spencer Target walked to the industry
beef on the table when Jim couldn't beef
for beef tragic yo got a body out here
that's crazy couldn't go couldn't go
beef for
beef then we got Mexican Zoidberg member
for 31 months Lord silver good night
sweet prince hopefully that retirement
package includes that yacht you always
wanted I don't think
so then we have up we got the homie
astop parrot King hold on a second
remember for five months Lord bronze the
line was held Cog survived and joystick
is still lurking I know what you're
talking about today was a good day hash
heal is well question is baked mac and
cheese really better yes yes yeah you
got you got to get down with
that forgive me I'm still good you're
good then we got uh Doctor Strange Love
Again $5 Super Chat had a friend in New
York stalking someone's apartment Window
for two hours cuz they were playing
Spider-Man 2 you NDA dudes need to be
more careful whoa oh yeah somebody get
caught out there that's crazy get caught
out there yes but draw your blinds
people if you playing some NDA games
facts I do that uh then we have nintend
onaku $5 Super Chat after 146 hours I
completed my first playthrough of
Starfield at the end of the Gen I'm sure
I'll look back and rank it among the
best it was amazing wow that's big
coming from there Taco salute
salute and we got hary channy remember
for 27 months Lord gold I know we're
we're not about to skip the CMA
approving ABK from last week that topic
needs to be brought forward to today
salute to the Lord's also condolences
stefans for his dad for sure for sure
yeah I said we got some bars for that
during the uh gy segments yeah we're
going to go back to some of last week's
topics no doubt what else we got then we
got Danny passion official
$5 super chatal the real got to get the
real that c is all right interviewing
first part interviewing first part he
needs to do he needs to run due to a
hurricane now Co due to a gas leag happy
Sunday though none of that none of that
wild and that is it for now let me uh
let me let me try to find some of these
other ones but go ahead you got to do no
doubt no oh look look who's right is
that is that who I think it is is that
him is that our l
I was poting people I was doing the um
the old you know this is where our
children are what's going on it's his
eye his ey Lord addict the co-host
totally to totally did that alarm I can
get a couple more St that snooze butt
action and what's funny is I actually
got a lot of like really good sleep last
night but I woke up this morning my
girl's out of town I was like I'm going
back to
bed I got no one that's going to come in
here exp me to be up and at it I'm going
back to bed and then Zachary walks in
there it's like hey you know it's like
like 109 right I'm like oh it's 109 I
guess I got to get up now co-host with
the coost a brother from another mother
the difficult game conquerer Lord of his
own world and the H of the young wolf
Lord addict back to back on a Sunday how
we doing what games what you been
playing I've been playing a lot of cyber
Punk also been playing uh a game I can't
speak about right
now yeah it's it's been an interesting
week man it's been an interesting week
no doubt no doubt so we got anything
else before we get into what we need to
talk about we got patreon questions
stuff we got to do yeah let's do that
this is being a pain in the rear right
now so you want me to do the patreon
question yeah yeah let's do that okay no
doubt so look we got to catch up I got
to catch up cuz obviously I ran out on
the podcast last week and we didn't get
a chance to do this so shout out to uh
snail killer all right he says hello
fellow Lords of the NZXT real oo he said
with all the great games that have come
out this year do you think the community
will be more demanding next year he's
speaking he's speaking specifically on
the quality of games that have come out
this year and what they offered PS I'll
pay money to see King change that Kraken
280 aiio to a 360 Kracken Elite and
install it too many good games this year
so King you're going to be able to you
you going to get cracking with your
cracking on on your NZXT
PC why would I do
that he want he said he gonna pay extra
money for you to change change that are
you are you gonna pay the money for the
piece and what happens if King messes
up is not doing none of that so you can
pay extra money if you choose I'm not
gonna do it no doubt no doubt so to his
initial question y'all he says um with
all the great games this year do you
think um The Gaming Community is going
to be more demand next year CU this year
has been so crazy hold hold on let me
address King Cory in the chat needs to
focus on his own show get someone else
that wants to be up on a Sunday I I
excuse me for over sleeping one week out
of the Year okay most of the time Co how
how early am at he here he be here early
so yeah you you can get on here with
that stuff I'm timing your ass out damn
and you can sit there in jail think
about your why you coming for King Cory
like that he he tried to get your
priorities right now he lucky I didn't
ban him you know that that's not Banning
a fence but you going to sit back you
sit there and look at the ground and say
don't Mass on time out he on damn you
going to sit there and think about your
action why you got to think about
it y adct vicious today that's crazy
getting King Curry the move salute King
Curry just trying to you know help out
but uh ad since you very um energetic
now um what about you know this year do
you think fans going to want more like
the type of games balers gate Starfield
they going to want more of these type of
Dr or this just one of them years yes
they're goingon to want more games like
Starfield but let's be real here like
bers gate it's amazing it's turnbas
though a lot of people don't mess with
turn-based games a lot of people no they
they cing about messing to turn-based
games because guess what I a't see none
of them share gameplay of that game and
it's been out for like a month on that
platform so it's just like look like I
loved it because I love turnbas I've
been very clear very open very
transparent that I love that type of
game play uh so if I say I like borders
gate that makes sense a lot of these
people are just capping thought it was
capping could that be the reason why Jim
is
leaving I don't think borders gay uh the
reason Jim Ryan got to do with Jim
that's crazy so last year versus this
year I mean this year versus potentially
next year I mean yeah I mean they're
always going to want more games of that
elk like to me like you know you always
going to watch your action games your
third person you know just just hashtag
just ones and and RPGs like this year
has been really good you know it's been
been really really good I think certain
a couple of things that we thought were
going to be better maybe didn't hit as
as crazy as we expected them to so that
you know is is this going to be an
all-timer
Year great year it's a great year oh you
don't think it's all time no I mean it's
a couple of things you know like again
it's you know even Starfield itself
right the the conversation around it it
hasn't been the Skyrim love right it
hasn't been on level so you know and
then you look at like a red fall and
things of that nature and just I don't
know it's it's it's been a great year um
I don't know if it stands with the tops
set the tops like you okay but again we
still have I mean what we have we have
Forza still coming got um Alan W balers
gate
love no it's my bag I just I I come on
I'm not even no yeah you got so much
going on I I got you I'm surprised I'm
surprised
Zelda came out this your tears dude I
got 10 minutes in Zelda and I had I got
a strong 10 minutes in Zelda no for real
like I have not had a chance to play so
I dropped Zelda too no it wasn't about
dropping it I want to play no I dropped
it because there so much stuff came out
and it's like I don't GNA be real like
at this point most likely that's coming
out for the switch to I might just Reby
that to play that at a better frame rate
I'm going to be real it cuz he knows
he's going to have to re it you know
said that like you just said that like
going make him re that matter matter of
factly like yeah I'll just Rey it just
like it was a great game it was but
after I did the first two regions I just
felt like I was playing breath of the
wild with some like some
DLC DLC right oh it's not
DL I don't want to call DLC because I
think that is too far but I would say
it's more DLC than Spider-Man Miles Mor
was like it's just like the only
difference really is some of the lands
in the sky now and now you got to talk
to certain PE like it felt the exact
same story go here do this go here do
that oh now you're fighting someone go
here do this go here do that like I
can't reut because I haven't
played what what when am I receiving
your knees oh for what well for what
what happened because right now you are
admitting that this game is just a
glorified DLC but when why would I
my when it was coming out that it was
glorified DLC he was like no it ain't
King it's got this and it got that and
then when it came out you was oh this
game of the year and this gonna be this
and Starfield gotta watch out for big
old Zelda you dropped it but you
finished starf here we go okay your
point but I'm going back to
where said why my knees in
danger and you like n it's not DC I mean
can I get half a kn
King banks on people not having receipts
remember King wants myy so bad he's
making [__] up now
Lang game of the year I can go back to
that episode go back to it write it down
take a picture clearly we got have to
hit the video tapes cuz I don't know
what's going on but I will jump in um I
think I think this year yeah I think
this year is amazing I think this is
fantastic year I want thinking I think
like Zelda's bad or anything it's just
like so but there was so much coming out
I just Valu play experiences over
something I played that I felt like I
already played listen see DLC M it's
been I know another controversial pick
but a lot of people love it it's Final
Fantasy 16 you know you got that out
there obviously you know Starfield
balers gate um yeah no that was year
Spider-Man's coming you know what I'm
saying smok was this
sh oh yeah it was this that's the two a
year that you get you get two a year you
got for spoken and
Spiderman year and one ain't even yours
M see octo came out this year people
love that yeah Final Fantasy 16 um
resent evil before remake SP remake
people love C what it C A Stars yeah
like it's just been crazy so I think you
know what it is it is it's just so many
more like when we talk about all-timers
right
you know whatever
2007 there's so many more games coming
out
now arm this year is crazy like I think
yeah oh Dia 4 came out the street
fighter Mortal Kombat bro this is a go
this year
can Legacy wow hog leg Yeah hog leg bro
come on like this this year can run up
against the best of
them you can make the argument that this
is one of the greatest years in the game
so next year we didn't even get Call of
Duty yet yeah facts next year that's on
Xbox that's Xbox Xbox on that so we be
Distributing that to everyone thank you
thank you for letting us know how the
legal process is going to go I just
don't want you to be shocked when you
boot it up and it says Microsoft studos
okay you want to let you want to be
clear on who owns that okay okay thank
you I okay thank you for the clarity I
appreciate that I just didn't want you
to think you got a forent copy got you
got you so as far and as far as next
year I do think I don't know if the
community be de I think the community to
chill like yo slow these games down
that's just me all right so we got more
Pat dip down the homie dip down oh he
always caus a violence here he go dip
down games in anime Sega versus micros
oh this was for last week when Peter was
here kog and sof are in charge of
assembling a team of three iconic Sega
characters from the Dreamcast era so
that's our job so we got to get three
iconic and we got to go up against I
have a feeling you're going we're going
to argue about this dip down is always
making us fight while addict and King
will do the same with the OG Xbox era so
the OG the old old joint you know what
I'm saying the Duke joint he said let
Peter Moore we can't do that now because
Peter Moore's gone um or the chat decide
whose team would win in a good
oldfashioned slobber knocker Jim Ross
Ross boy so s me and you got to come up
with three Dreamcast Eric Sega
characters King and adct got to come up
with three from the OG Xbox like you
know
I don't know what was back then um Halo
one I guess you know um whatever and all
right so I'm I'm going to say yo what up
Alex what's going on all right so I'm
must say these have to be Sega
characters or games that came out on
Dreamcast he says a team of three iconic
Sega characters yeah okay I think this
is unfair to us though no or not cuz
they gonna have Master Chief off rip off
Rip r they got Master Chief you have
Sonic off rip we got Sonic we going
Sonic goes gold and that's that's like
having Goku on your team who we got who
we going who we going who the other two
though we stga characters and he's
limiting us to Dreamcast era yeah
Dreamcast era Sega we we have Crazy Taxi
we going have we got car from Crazy Taxi
we have what we oh you want to throw you
want to throw r r from Shu you want to
throw him in or he he not strong enough
he not strong I mean he's he oh we go
with the boss let's go with land D you
want to go with
land let's go we got land D okay so we
got land D these dud is wild crazy and
we got Sonic I got to figure out who
thir let me see House of the Dead zombie
we need somebody we need somebody op cuz
ADD G pick some op stuff I know how him
and King do they gonna pick some power
level not really a lot like I can't pick
a lot of people like that on the
original Xbox like like Goku's not on
the original Xbox there's not really any
anime who y'all three King who y'all
going with with OG Xbox who y'all going
to so they have to be exclusives right
I'm definitely going with massach Chief
we already yeah I got Mass Chief that's
a W rap yep um spawn what a spawn game
on the OG xBox wasn't he on um the but
wait are are they all wait are you
allowed hold on are you guys you have to
get no you have to get Sega you have to
get Xbox characters it says well well
Swan is the Xbox character because it
was released on Xbox console and it was
exclusive to the Xbox console remember
PlayStation had hayi or what you going
to do y bone ninja guiding ninja guiding
don't worry I was about to use that okay
okay okay Alex made a good point we got
Sonic with the emeralds yeah sonic is
the most OP character in we
got I don't think we can beat like you
can fight all six of our characters of
Sonic and win youin G Master Chief ain't
gonna say today he ain't gonna no master
chief ain't G Sonic Sonic not Sonic with
nothing just running could beat Master
Chief what about what about C wasn't it
CTO dude out around that time I mean
Raven do something but Star Killer I
mean I don't know how like the what kind
of resistance Sonic would have against
the forest like if Sonic if Sonic has no
resistance to the force then Raven would
probably demolish that dude but I if
here's again too like can Raven get him
just a second enough before he cuz to me
Sonic can get snap his neck and run
right back in a second and they nothing
ren do
going to go with Air's
WRA
damn what I'm saying he's liing us to
Sega characters and Y get the whole game
they get the whole Xbox actually
actually King I I got someone I got
someone the the the Fable hero because
he can slow time down Sonic's out of
here oh you go OG Fable okay no doubt I
like so you got the Fable what was y
three the um I don't want his three you
don't want the so y'all got to hurry up
cuz we got to get we got more question I
I want the Fable character Raven mhm and
and um okay I'll give you Star Killer
right Star Killer was on the Star Killer
was Unleashed King yes so don't take um
whatam Star Killer came out on a regular
OG Xbox right it was a 360 game okay so
then we got to take you got take R okay
so you got that okay I I agree with you
Raven then I I'll choose two fa
characters then I'm
taking Ra was with
yeah I'm taking I'm taking Jack of
Blades the hero from Fable and Raven
from Ni of the Republic is that what
y'all both agree on oh we have to agree
on yeah it's addict and King have to
agree and Cog and sof have to agree on
the three and then the matchup the chat
I guess I want spawn I want okay that
we'll do spawn okay the Fable character
and who's the third master chief Master
Chief I feel like I feel like Raven's a
better choice man y'all disrespect
master I'm not going to do that though
I'm going to take Master Chief because
he's a strategist and remember he the
luckiest he luck I don't care about luck
the M Raven is is a Sith Lord like
decide we got more questions come on
decide we already took Ren I we both got
Raven so it's just the last character is
Master Chief I choose master chief you
choose Raven last character we both got
to choose the time stoer D from Fable
good we good all right cool cool and S
we good on all three Dam so wait who did
we grab we got son Sonic with the we got
Sonic with the emeralds we literally
that's the
MVP here's the thing are you think you
think our characters are just going to
let Sonic fuse with the emeralds I'm
just saying we got Sonic with the
emeralds he pulls those out like dude
slow time down kill him I see or or can
we allowed to pick any the so caliber D
yeah so let's who pick Inferno the boss
whoever the boss Inferno Inferno it's
got to be the character from the like
that that was exclusive to
the exus
dreamus character that was exclusive he
said the boss we got the boss that's it
Sonic
Inferno Inferno how about um how about
guts from um sword of the berserk sword
of the berserk he's crazy he was crazy
I'm going to be real with you King ain't
nothing they saying I see them winning
so Shen's in the bushes so Shen anybody
I would say yeah I would say Rio has to
go Rio to go no land guts guts guts will
murder him yeah he get murdered so guts
we going to go with guts we go with guts
okay so we won continue chat let let let
y'all know whose team is it is it a who
team one out of that three you know what
I'm saying for each team's three all
right no doubt no doubt secretly the
samb Amigo
Monkey Crazy Taxi for the wi all right
so then the next joint while you put
that pole up dip down got us they they
to yo we got all right so um dip down
anime again oh here he go he a giant we
got's up I just thought about an
invincible character who let's go Frank
Shamrock from the
UFC the UFC game he's a beast he was
undefeated no doubt no doubt all right
so a giant asteroid is going to destroy
the world due to reasons unless the four
of you can come to an agreement which
video game fighting series is the
greatest of all time there can only be
one save the world
second I think addict's goingon to kill
us cuz he don't never agree with nothing
I'm just pick whatever you guys pick I
don't care I'm listen Moral Kombat is on
fire right now but I I can't go against
Tekken but Sol I'm a street fighter guy
I I'm a street fighter guy so you know
what Sol
y
we all agree I go with Street Fighter
Street Fighter started with absolutely
zero story
yeah all over the world with the busted
mouth but wait s how you how you going
to do this but you you you the you the
grappler you the he being he being he
being very
disruptive cuz and then he got his
namesake in the game Brian Fury got his
wrestling character with King how you
doing this to us I no mind it's it's
Street Fighter
wow that's crazy it's Street Fighter the
basis for the basis for combat period in
in a whole bunch of games 3D games 2D
games comes off of what what they what
they managed to do with Street Fighter
2o I told y'all I told you on the first
LSM uh live event that that denan won
because I will
ah I I I pick whoever has the most picks
I don't care like I I would naturally
probably pick Mortal Kombat but for for
for the show's sake I'm not picking that
because I don't care enough to care yeah
so it's whatever Tekken this asteroid
this asteroid is destroying the world
because we I am not moving off Tekken
s's not moving just want to take some
fake game storyline well see why why
thees story have to be this decided fact
now all of a sudden Mortal Kombat one
had this amazing story didn't they say
that they had the best story what had
the best story no did he he didn't say
that did he say that no no no no he said
what's the best fighting series of all
time they can only I thought I thought
he says uh fighting game s okay anyway
yeah oh fighting game series yeah he
said what's the fight of all time yeah
what that changes
everything here we go now got oh why
that change everything sir the greatest
fight fighting game series of all time
all time
series F wow I mean I can't okay I'm in
Street Fighter now gota be we dying no
no the reason why C the reason
why I know Street Fighter it's the I
know I
know it started it all and it's
still yeah that's the thing it got to be
the greatest I don't no to we're dying
when when Tekken came I'm sorry that
that was y could have got me with
virtual Fighters I have said that but no
don't get me wrong I get the history
though I get the history yeah this
recent uh Street Fighter it's uh it's
fire oh it's fire yeah a lot of people
lik it we gonna move on the world is
dead um Brian it might it might lose to
MK1 though Hest it's the third right now
but anyway all right so last one this is
from this week he said oh no you didn't
say way now you
know now you know the're pecking on all
right so Brian says hello Lords after
the leak of the new Xbox controller and
push towards Cloud platform I started to
think about the controller and what that
might mean going forward with the
eventual eventuality of consoles being
replaced by the cloud do you think the
controller will replace the console will
people be lining up to get the elite 8.0
or the Dual sense 10 If This Were to be
the case who would have the
advantage yes would have the advantage
of that Advantage I don't think they're
doing that but Xbox would have the
advantage of that I
think it's going to lead towards an
option way but I don't think they'll
ever try to do anything like permanently
okay yeah so y all agree so yeah I don't
think it's going to be I don't think the
there's going to be more Hardware in in
the controller right obviously the
picking it up and it waking up and and
it's going to wake up you know it's
going to be able to be used with any
number of different screens um and and
you know cloud or whatever or or native
or local platform whatever but yeah it's
it itself is not going to become cuz I
know what he means cuz they they have
some controllers they sell you know
those those third party things you see
oh the controller has has all of the the
Atari uh you know Library built into it
or something like that like no it's not
gonna be that it's not gonna be that but
this is they're building a controller
that can be used on a variety of
different platforms yes absolutely so I
do think you know don't I agree I don't
think it will replace the console
completely cuz I think Hardware but it
will definitely allow you to go to any
screen you know what I mean kind of
thing we'll talk about that a little
later so that's it we are caught up on
the patreon questions thank youall for
being patient cuz we missed um we want I
want to do the poll and then you want me
to do I me you want to do super chats
after again cuz I know one more came in
or you want me to do the poll couple
more came in let me get let me get
something from last week so we got Sith
Lord remember for 14 months Lord bronze
uh thank you Peter Moore for everything
you've done for the Xbox and Sega I
appreciate it very much and I thinkk you
you're a great role model for the
business oh absolutely super proud of
that interview then I have to go scroll
forward cuz for whatever reason it is
not letting me um it is not letting me
yeah shout out to one bad mother he said
I creative destruction a lot of what
Peter Mo said in part two ties to this
Jim Ryan so many stuff you talking about
yeah yeah creative destruction line was
very key and and how he was talking
about the future
absolutely 100% because it's you got to
have you can't be afraid you can't be
afraid and sometimes not hold the line
blow it up yeah he's quick to blow stuff
up when you see how it's going to be
later on 10 years from now and now I'm
not getting anymore all right all don't
worry you want there's some new ones
came in though I see yeah actually okay
okay here I got a couple of more we got
fresh dude 519 310 $2 Super Chat King
what's the name of those [__] oh wait I
got that you I've read that yeah the
gazel he did that he did
that n this why is this you joint wer
yeah it's giving me or I read some of
these you may have read it let's just
somebody talking about Strange Love talk
about uh Cognito steaks and truffle
butter yeah yeah we we did
that we did that no need to repeat none
of that oh you want to get the latest
let me go let me go to the latest stuff
hold on a second hold on a second let me
see Danny passion we got homeless bird5
Super Chat H to the realm don't sleep on
cyberpunk free 2.0 patch The Reflex
skill tree is a blast with enhanced
dashing and Katana deflections yeah we
gonna
talk then we got Gerald Mack $5 Super
Chat Jim said i' be daming changing that
crazy ass fan base bump that I'm out of
here run me my breath wow okay said run
me my
breath God nintend onaku $5 Super Chat
adct must be a different type of addict
that tears of the kingdom is more DLC
Than Miles Morales he's still upset
about Zelda glowing up sh my I I I I
love Zelda it's just I just couldn't
bring myself to finish it not the one
calling it DLC I am and I stand on it
shout out shout out to the homie one
away dragons up in in episode 100
yesterday that was what's up man he said
King he said charot is a punk scared to
fight
okay what what you want me to say
just talking he just talking he say he
directed opportunity to do it yesterday
and he did you you know what El King it
looks like that fight's over it said
King and adct we won by 77% so far know
you 76 you probably did something
biased n we just picked a better tee
yeah anyway
continue I don't want to accept the law
yeah we had to delve into this deep
library of superheroes the panon of
Dreamcast her continue then we got Danny
Bo we got odd Emperor God Emperor sopa
King once again gifted five more IL
memberships thank you appreciate
absolutely appreciate that we got Danny
passion official what get $5 Super Chat
the teeken eight silently move to next
year it is next year it's January next
year by the way no one is talking about
lies of p and the Lords of the Fall
includ 2023 is is one of the best years
in gaming yeah yeah lot be it's crazy
I ain't played Li I even boot it that's
how crazy this year has been and then we
got Robert Kell $2 Super Chat so is King
going to be the new Sony
CEO if I was we would
win we good what else we got then we got
Robert kellet to uh $2 Super Chat Tekken
wins by default for not having MTX BS
yeah that's
right then we got Robert Kelly again $2
Super Chat three weeks later at the gym
feeling fire salute as well get that get
that sure then we got Robert Kell once
again $5 Super Chat you got to check out
the Frontiers update Tails Knuckles and
Amy playable new Cyber levels and much
harder difficulty transform the game
didn't know I haven't played that in a
while psych shout out to shout out to
everborn shout out to everborn shout out
to MADD I know he go hard with
it we got yah baby fa $10 Super Chat one
of the great things about your
interviews with notable gaming figures
is they give great info on the history
of the industry that will be referenced
for years to come salute salute thank
you yeah we got a lot of positive vibes
man Peter was awesome the fact he gave
us a part two and more industry Insight
again Legend super proud and all his
journeys you can learn so much of what
things he's helped usher in to the games
industry to this day from Subscription
Service you name it like and just being
a challenger brand it's just amazing to
hear here so yeah definitely highly
recommend yall go to part two he had
even more bars we good yep we're good
all right cool um just want to get the
poll last poll results are in the people
poking to the question with the latest
Sony state of play and Nintendo Direct
both making their reveals on the same
day which show resonated with you the
most the winner of the poll at 61% of
the vote was I don't care about none of
that let's see what Xbox does at the
Tokyo game show coming it at second
place uh 20% of the vote was uh
Playstation uh Game of the Year
Contender Spider-Man 2 Final Fantasy 7
rebirth impressive showing with release
date plus commitment to psvr 2 um last
place 18% was massive Nintendo first
party offerings third party and titles
releasing this year and 2024 group shout
out to all those who participated Lord
addict they oh he jumped out but they
was talking about they they was excited
for Tokyo game show which we will talk
about later and then I think beta Cipher
came in with um Super Chat we got beta
Cipher $5 Super Chat m the greatest
fighter ever is the Forgotten one I need
a new Power Stone game ASAP no no Rocky
all love Lords and great show so far
actually the greatest fighter ever is
toe ball number one toe ball oh classic
classic classic 60 FP goodness so before
we get to the top before we get to the
topic s um Lord's got some new powers
man powered
up yeah
NZXT you see that Flex on the on the
side you see the wolf powering up over
there that purple nple you know what I'm
saying so yeah salute to SXT obviously
the Lords have partn it up you know what
I'm saying for the crest in the chat and
uh yeah if you're looking to get
yourself a new
build you know what I'm saying you can
show us your new build we got the links
in the description and in the uh pin at
the top of the chat use that link if you
want to power up you want to get that
new pspc rig you want to get that FSR
you want to do whatever you want to do
you know what I'm saying use that link
it reps helps the Lords you know what
I'm saying and uh yeah let y'all talk
about y'all I mean for me I mean if they
want to be on the Forefront of where all
PlayStation games will be head over to
the
PC yo
you go to NZXT and make sure that you
build your bill without promo code to
make sure you get a chance to play all
Sony new tit day and dat on the PC
playst oh now day and dat new
mantra PlayStation 6 won't be coming out
so they need some place to go and they
be on the
steam so yeah show us your build y'all
like I said if you looking I think shout
out to the homie Rand out though I was
listen to Xbox 2 you Le a new build Sir
I heard you talking about looking at a
4090 or something like that you know
what I'm saying right now what's my GPU
looking like I mean I'm on the AMD side
of things I'm on the 41st side of the
AMD thing you know what I'm saying so
I'm got that ryzen 7 that 7800 x3d on
the 41st side of the the afd yeah that's
our CPU that's the CP yeah yeah yeah
then that GPU so that that RX 7900 X
7900 XTX yeah yeah yeah so what's what's
that equivalent to the on on the other
side it's it's it's we're not making
comparisons here we're not doing that
but it's it's very powerful for my
understand it's very powerful I could I
run the latest games could I do R tra
you can run the latest games you play
Starfield at over 60 frames per second
oh the way Todd intend to God Howard in
oh yeah God you know God how would allow
you to play wherever you wanted to play
CPU and the CPU the ryzen 7 the 7800 x3d
is actually as of right now the fastest
gaming CPU on the market wow that's
crazy because because of the fact that
it has less cores than other uh CPUs
even in the even in the AMD lineup and
the ryzen lineup uh it's more focused
specifically like Brute Force for gaming
whereas other other CPUs with more cores
uh do kind of more they're great for
gaming but you they also do even an even
better job for multitasking this is a
pure sort of gaming CPU and it and it
really I want to talk about someone said
breaking news uh IOP has uh they IOP has
been acquired by NXT you know the
interesting part about it NZXT is like
one of the only companies I know that
just want us to be us yeah yeah facts
facts like there were there was no like
terms or anything he's look we we just
want you to help you produce the amazing
show you already produced yeah because I
was like um if it came with I can't
disparage and go at Sony know I'm sorry
I would have to refuse this partnership
no they told me they said we all for the
smoke they for thex told you yeah he
said you know we we we we look forward
tox did not say that did not say that is
not so actually the conversation that we
had right was
okay no PlayStation 6 that's what we say
so they got to go to PC I said how can I
play my returnal better than than how it
was initiated on the PlayStation 5 he
said I got a PC for you that's what he
told me you know crazy I I've seen
people say they want us to to play that
returnal together keing because it has a
co-op feature but we gonna do it on the
PC where it's great or we gonna do it on
Playstation where it's just average wow
wow wow wait talk about I don't I want
to know because my pc be doing that I
want to know um does it uh on the
PlayStation right does it still crash
where is this going where is this what
this got to do with no cuz I want to
play returnal in the greatness we
playing it on the PC now this is what
with you know this is like expressly
what they said not to do right yeah he
outside but um like I was
saying like you were
saying like was saying the conversation
that we
had was really about like okay
when we talk when we talk about like a
full AMD build right okay end of the day
most of our community right if you come
into our our chat you're you're on Xbox
you're on Playstation also some get
people on Nintendo as well but that's a
that's a different Hardware manufacturer
but everybody's sort of in the AMD
family already right so we said okay
this is perfect when you want to talk
about something being a what is it
serendipitous and sort of it flows
together perfectly the fact that this is
a full AMD build so the stuff that we're
experiencing on these new computers is
stuff that is going to is either already
on the console side or it's going to
come to fruition on the on the console
side like for instance it was it's kind
of even though last week we had to you
know break and leave in a way it's kind
of cool because what happened is in the
in the following week FSR 3.0 dropped
right yeah so FSR 3.0 is now available
on um pretty much a a a wide sort of
swath of different gpus including gpus
on the other side of the the AMD uh on
the other side right so the great thing
about FSR 3.0 is that it it it has the
sort of the upscaling technology right
in addition to that it also is debuting
frame generation right um so so far they
only two games that have it I don't have
either of these two games I don't know
that I'm going to get either these two
games it's Immortals of Aven which is
the one I'm probably I would get and for
spoken I'm not good you're not going
show
oh okay yeah behave I'm just saying they
listen I got a PC to play at the highest
level this is what I'm doing this I'm
just asking if I can play the high you
going utilize that in for spoken and you
go you know what you know what I I think
I might get for spoken just to play at
the highest level I think I'm going do
that yeah okay yeah go go with God
Son so um I haven't been able to test it
out myself yet yeah but the jump from
2.0 is supposed to be significant and
the performance again when you talk
about when you're getting at this level
right the cool thing about this PC and
what I've done so far is every single
game that I throw at it I turn off all
sorts of frame generation I turn off all
of it to see if the PC can handle it on
that top okay on that and the truth of
the matter is that the answer to that is
pretty yes like wow it kind of doesn't
need it um when you do need it though uh
and the thing is I'm running since I
have it connected to my TV I'm running
it at 4K so that you certain things
you'll get like a little hits here there
whatever but apart from that if you're
running it at a lower resolution this PC
is such a beast that you really don't
need all that stuff no doubt but that
said when we start to get the games that
really utilize this tech and and are
really going to push Tech forward this
is obviously great stuff to have because
now you can run your game internally at
a lower resolution and then up up you
know upscale it up to 4K and you utilize
all of these tools to still get a
picture that is super comparable to a
native 4K uh picture right and this jump
in FSR is is really really substantial
is really substantial so from what I've
seen so far and you know you know what a
bigger news is man you guys don't know
this uh the chat doesn't but sa is
pushing this
hard
like ratted me out last listen listen as
the iron bank and the one who do who dos
out money when you when you I refuse I
you are not going to willingly play the
inferior version but because you want to
we've been
bullied the I was saying what I was
saying I am bullying the rest of the
Lords into playing on PC when I deem it
necessary you know what's funny sof
deems it necessary as long as it
financially makes sense when I'm like yo
you just got to buy one copy of returnal
and we good but you want to buy two two
on PCS okay that's right that's will
y you know what I I could have gotten
addict the $30 code for Phantom Liberty
on Xbox no no no why is that why is that
why is that because he's playing it on
this be the player three that's why heed
shout out player three and Shout Shout
Out tot for again allowing the
customizations your bill you don't have
to go all out you go you can you can get
your customer the check that link out if
you guys are in the realm of looking for
a new rig use that link it's pinned at
the top and again it'll help us support
the podcast again shout out to our
partners good friends at NZXT love the
relationship y'all no doubt get that
player three build it is is it is it
isely it is crazy and again you guys are
already in the AMD family check it out
it is it's special plus I want to point
out too you know there other player
builds are pretty pretty solid too like
you know uh the one we got the one we
needed because we do a lot with these
PCS we edit with these PCS we stream
with these PCS you know play games with
these PCS like if you don't do all this
extra stuff and you just want something
to play fortnite with King you could do
that so King I don't did you understand
he what he with by the Kraken right the
Kraken is the the the the CPU Cooler if
you okay I didn't know you understood it
was something
else no doubt I just push play and it
yeah I feel you I feel you if something
goes wrong I'm calling
Cog definitely adct ad is FaceTime yeah
exactly or or KATU I'm messing with it
I'm not messing with it anymore either
so no doubt no doubt so we are all good
and again check out that that amazing
overlay by by Sean La you see the power
of the n6 feeding you see it feeding
feeding the wol feeding the podcast kind
of fire but anyway that's what we got we
going to get into these topics finally
unless we got any Super chats uh we got
yeah oh I think adct read this one
already breaking IOP has been acquired
by NZXT shout out to y' Baby fa $2 Super
Chat then we got Robert kellet $2 Super
Chat so will Microsoft acquire you guys
next amen amen said amen you want me to
[__] I don't
care out of pocket hustle asked you I'll
be worse than K hustle asked what's uh
your your your PC builds sir he said
what the Lord's PC bills hustle that
motivate hindsight withle so it is the
if you hustle if you go to the NXT
website it's the player 3 AMD Edition
put the I'll put the link in the chat
that is that is exactly our build yeah
go check that out play it three all no
doubt what we probably need to do is
just put the specs in the description so
people like y if you want to see in the
description yeah so really quickly like
we said before it comes with a ryzen
77800 x3d CPU and the GPU is a Radeon RX
XTX um you if you look online it'll tell
you what they compareed to um if you're
looking at you know at the opposition or
whatever yeah no doubt no doubt and
remember use the link that's pinned at
the top if somebody can copy that and
put that in there if someone so they can
put it back in the chat just so they can
see if they're looking to use that link
that really helps the Lords man put put
you you know I'm sorry yeah I didn't I
didn't use that word use that link use
that link it's pinned at the top I see
it I see it yeah use that link you know
what I'm saying support the Lord show us
your build with NZXT all right we are
good we got to get to it now so um
salute uh lot lot of news has broken and
I guess we going to start off with the
main one um Jim Ryan this is King's
topic uh yeah new management structure
of Sony interactive entertainment Jim
Ryan to retire next spring and heroki
toi to assume uh interim CEO role while
keeping his current role as Sony group
so um yeah it was announced they said
that effective um um immediately that uh
ctive mean but uh CIO president and CEO
Jim Ryan has made the decision to retire
in March of 2024 after almost 30 years
with the PlayStation business to support
Ry in this transition as we talked about
um CFO and coo o heroki to will assume
the role of chairman of Si effective
October
2023 and then um he will be appointed
into CEO why you got to do the duplicate
lab anyway so um yeah Jim Ryan was there
since uh like in 94 and then um since
then he's held a number of senior
positions at the company including
president of s head of global sales and
marketing at s Deputy president of s
since January 2018 before appointed s
president and CEO and then MH yes I said
wow oh okay um yida has had a comment he
said Jim Ryan was an INSP inspirational
leader throughout this entire period
with us but never more so and overseeing
the launch of the PlayStation 5 in the
midst of the global coid pandemic so he
goes on again to continue to Rave and
talk about how you know he's helped the
business Jim Ryan has made his statement
officially after 30 years I've made the
decision to retire from si in March of
2024 I've relished the opp Unity to have
a job I love in a very special company
working with great people and incredible
Partners but I found it increasingly
difficult to reconcile living in Europe
and working in North America I will
leave having being privileged to work on
products that touch millions of lives
across the world PlayStation will always
be a part of my life and I feel more
optimistic than ever about the future of
siie I want to thank yidan for placing
so much trust in me and being an
incredible supportive sensitive
supportive lead when did he take over
the as the boss um when did he take over
it said 2019 I think it was I think
Deputy president of Si since January
2018 before being Point yeah may have
been 2019 may be right there yeah but
came in at the tail end of the
PlayStation 4 right he's been with Sony
but as far as talking about the head
talk about talking about being the head
yeah yeah yeah that that I'm trying to
get the clarity there because it it
doesn't say specifically it just said
that he Deputy president say since 2018
so it could be between that 2018 201
so so to be clear too he didn't he
didn't specifically replace Shawn leaden
they were different they're different
positions so technically like sea leen's
replacement was Herman hulst right and
and not necessarily like Jim would is
like the boss of everything right like
Jack Tron like like a like Jack like a
Jackie t or an Andrew house or something
like that yeah yeah so you know yes
crazy I was um looking he he wasn't
there that long like in that position
like three four years
yeah so King this is your topic
obviously of course it's King's talk the
realm wants to hear from you I'm I'm
supposed to let you talk I'm mute my mic
so n man you got to beat your m i want
you in on this I told you dudes Jim
wouldn't make it past the next fiscal
period dude said King he has in record
sales he has a game of the year
candidate coming out he has game of the
Year's multiple years that has been
nominated your man has diservice he
Consolidated he's making money hand over
fist I said I don't care what you saying
he's out my next fiscal period k your a
crackpot your man is gone by D
period
yo yall so successful you stop reporting
numbers you're so successful you didn't
pay the rent to get back the customers
data you talking about the leak what you
about they leak they said yo we got your
customers data they said we don't care
about the customer do what you got to do
B he did not say that we don't negotiate
with terrorist and close the
door that's how much they care about the
fan base they care about you so much
before Jim left he said I'm going to
raise the price of the service he said
and gu guess what he killed the Slate of
all the games remember y'all sitting
there talking about we got games coming
out this that and the third y'all know
what's coming out now have absolutely no
IDE but what you do know is y got 10
games of services and he just raised the
price on the
services he said before I leave this is
how much I love
y'all yo that is kind of
funny like he left and was like here's
my partying gift Savage yo he went out
and snitched put a light on top of Sony
Stony can't do their underhanded deals
no more y'all can't do the stuff that y'
was doing with Squid that's why squid G
is under on Xbox because the FTC got the
contracts they said yo young man went
over there imagine you going to the
teacher snitching on somebody and he
lock you
up why they locked him up how Jim is
gonna tell on Xbox and he get
canned he like Phil is doing Mad stuff
why I got to go
so so this is a direct result of of no
this is a direct result of the ABK deal
okay sh uh Sony you could have took the
deal and got more games you just got
Call of Duty for 10 years you got the
same contract everybody else got if
you're supposed to be Sony Elite no more
ABK games for you all you negotiated was
successfully was Call of Duty you lost
the deal is going to go through and they
G to have ABK now the money that you
spending on Call of Duty got to go to
the the the funny part too is they they
were offering the full ride like they
it's it's like it's like being offered
like a full ride scholarship to a a
school and try to negotiate higher than
that and they end up not getting it end
up getting like okay you get one class
you get one class you got to pay for the
rest you got a EBT card and a bus
pass they said that is over that boat
has sealed yo you are
that was the officially the worst
negotiation tactic ever like you sold
all the all the stuff that came out none
of the information would have came out
none of these uh back door stuff would
have came out none of that redactor
stuff would have came out and I keep on
hearing the PlayStation fan base saying
Jim is leaving on a high
note bro you literally don't know what's
going on for the next four years well
that's one let let you talk you had two
piss paw shows the one game that you
launched this year was an exclusive was
a dud y talk about redf y'all got to get
together together the services they told
you is going up by 40 bucks not
$1 where's this number come from who the
hell just said 40 bucks like somebody
said 40 bucks and they felt that it was
worth it the service ain't even worth
what they asking now and this dude
stepped out and said 40 bucks he did a
passion project was called VR right that
didn't sell he done another passion
project right before he leave he put y
right in the
red the portal a passion project too he
did all the passion project all the
stuff he wanted to do remember we
sitting there saying why is this stuff
coming out who it selling to he did
Passion projects to SN you guys CU he
knew he was gonna lose the ABK deal he
said you know what I'mma sync this whole
[__] and he is your Donnie he's your
Donnie and let me tell you this y'all
don't got enough money to survive this
oh my God so boy here we go your money
when bung here we go the end always ps6
you know you know go back to that let me
hear this let me hear this and I told
told you he was leaving right y'all
laughed true the joke's on you now no no
you're right predicted no no no not you
not you I'm talking about them
now I'm telling you Bungie is going to
leave oh this this the new one Prophet
this this one out why bu bunie is going
to leave because all the work is being
thrown on Bungie Destiny has been
absolute garbage since Sony has acquired
them I cannot dispute that the stuff
that has been going on with Bungie you
know why it's garbage because Bungie is
overwork and
underpaid doing everything else worrying
about Marathon worrying about 10 games
of services they're going to leave you
know how she gets when she don't like
doing extra work she's out of there and
she has the prenup already signed she
good money and everybody gonna get paid
and she gonna go away Hulk said they
contract is ill they she was he was
surprised that Sony agreed to a level of
contract Freedom that um Bungie has you
know agreed to but yeah no no continue
continue no I mean this I just I I just
want to
say he was your
Donnie and the reason why I believe
y'all can't recover from
this Microsoft is building
steam you don't have enough time to play
catchup a god of war is not gonna work
it ain't gonna work y'all can try y
could be y'all can have him in
Egypt in Horus he be do all EGP heard I
I hate to interrupt because I'm not
supposed to but I just had to ask a
quick question so you're saying the
reason why the um the God of War stuff
is not going to work because like like
like your old analogy when you had
remember when you had all the games the
the the bangers and you had God of War
the Spider-Man and you said that Jim
said all of this doesn't equal to this
one game because of the revenue from
that so you saying now because of the
Call of Duty situation is that they're
in a bad spot that the hash just ain't
going to save them it's a Cascade of
things you raise the price on your
service so you're going to make people
leave the service right CU you you you
just gave them an ultimatum get down a
lay down right you already know y'all
get TCL television y'all cheat so y'all
GNA lay down y'all be like nope I'm not
about this I'm out of here I'm not going
to pay for your service you already know
PlayStation dudes was bulking at the
fact that they did have to pay for
something when y when yall tricked them
that time remember y'all never play for
online um that' be
39 so okay M the Microsoft having this
uh head start with Services right
Microsoft having Head Start in
multiplayer Microsoft taking your most
uh coveted Advantage which was Call of
Duty and the marketing rights that's
going to be removed from you guys so
that's going to be on Xbox you can't no
longer run out there and be like yo all
you do is this dumb um Call of Duty's
only over here over yeah the B that 500
million that you was paying the um uh
Activision that's going to Microsoft
that's your
demise you're absolutely right with with
that I won't push back my my question to
you is but what about Jim's the success
as far as the console sales as far as
dominating Sony's most greatest era as
far as sales the conso sold to scalpers
oh my God the console sold to you know
why I can say the console sold to
scalpers the ratio to games out there to
consoles don't match okay they don't
match
like not even 1% of your your your fan
Bas purchase game is weird it don't
match it don't match with the online you
got 20 something five million online
dudes why are none of them buying
anything like why does Jim have to leave
now in a cloak of secrecy like I'm out
of here you know me traveling back and
forth has been too much you caused the
problem like if if you never said what
you said you know what you did when you
went to Brazil you tried to speak in
Spanish it didn't work out we found out
what you did now now you're upset
because it didn't go your way they don't
speak
Spanish speak
let okay so but the problem is you
started all of this he started now it
didn't go your way okay okay you said we
have nothing to compete with Call of
Duty he did say that he did say that
that's after you brought Buie like yeah
that's a fact like a week later that's a
fact so nothing you got can compete with
it so that means you're God of War
remember what I told y'all that means
you're Horizon that means you're
Spider-Man can't compete with Call of
Duty he did say that so now that Call of
Duty is here what did he say I cannot
compete I'm out of here that's it oh so
that's what so so so your blame is the
ABK failure to get the deal blocked that
is part that part is is is the was the
demise so so so this is a rules his
retirement is a rul to you that's right
no it's not a rul he really retired he
really looked at it and was like oh hell
no I'm not going back in there like when
the last time you saw him he SN okay
that was the last time you saw him right
so when you when we saw the play Stay to
play you thought he was going to come
out they send somebody else out and then
they did what was that game Happy Feet
baby steps they didn't baby steps you
should have known from baby steps it was
a rap for you dudes it is absolutely
done and I'm having the time of my life
because I told you was going to happened
and y'all looked at me and said King he
ain't going nowhere he's the most
successful that we had no what he did
was he crapped on Japan took those
people out of there took them over to
the EU and he made that his home base
the EU is fighting like hell for him
right now to get the ABK deal because
they know once it's over there's no
PlayStation 6 they want to save their
PlayStation 6 I'm down with y'all but um
no it's not gonna happen but listen Jim
thank you thank you so much for all the
damage you did so so so so in your eyee
just so I'm clear yes this is a dawn
matrick situation oh God that so despite
the console sales despite the success of
this being one of the best PlayStation
era for him you your thought process is
that he's done long-term damage that
they're not going to be able to recover
from he told them he doesn't care about
any other games except for Blockbuster
the triple a title that's a fact he said
that Shawn leaden Phil Dominus Maximus a
really Spencer and everybody in the
industry says AAA titles are not
sustainable because the prices of these
games have gone up astronomically and
you do not get a return on investment
especially when Sony games are one and
done there's no multiplayer component to
these games so you spend x amount of
dollars on Horizon you want money back
right it don't matter if it sells a a a
th000 copies when it's
$10 they want to sell at Peak price
remember he raised the price on y'all
the industry had to follow right he did
raise he started they started the $70
mov right but what about what about the
remixing and the remaking and then
moving with the movies and then the PC
getting the money on the back end with
let me let me let me do this let me let
me say this let's go to Every fan fan
person of of PlayStation because you're
not a boy you a person you know fan
person of PlayStation uh console okay
does Sony look the
same they feel I really want you to take
a deep reflection on that question I
know y'all throw out numbers and stuff
y' all like to throw out numbers until
one day it really fell a blockbuster was
at the top of the Heap until one day
y'all went outside and it's gone y'all
don't even use VCRs no more but I want
y'all to just really think of this has
PlayStation looked like PlayStation this
year look at it from the two wack game
shows those shows was horrible for
spoken came out y'all was beating your
chest on that Final Fantasy came out it
was a good game but it wasn't a good
Final Fantasy game now you got The Last
Hope The Last Hope is Spiderman and I
told y'all before it's DLC I'm going to
call it Game of the Year for me but it's
still the same thing y'all have what
what four Spider-Man games in five
years yo how many times the remix it
they remix it yeah you get to play Miles
Morales in this one you get to play
Spider-Man in this one you get to play
both and let's remix what we gave you
they remixing the remix they they Puff
Daddy in it
Char you with tax yo I'm so sick and
tired of you guys pumping out your chest
acting like something is really
happening when the world is passing you
by you you outside of your house
screaming dialup this is what you doing
you yelling dialup and dudes is on DSL
and Wifi you you out there on you on a
rotary phone and everybody got iPhone
I'm but so sad last point he you have to
give him credit for at least you
yourself with when he was pushing the PC
ports he pushing the live service and
the mobile you was like yo Jim is is on
it you was with him I with that I want
him to do that that's the closest you
that's get over to the PC yeah leave
this Hardware stuff alone you're not
good at that let's leave that alone
let's put that over there right let's go
back to being a developer let's do this
let's how about this how about this how
about you go make games since you make
great single first person story driven
games so
are you saying that they're going to be
third party eventually yes or they going
to be purchased by Apple or or Netflix
one of the two they don't got enough
money for this fight already saw it yo
you know how you going to leave you you
acting like he leaving on top I mean he
he already planned his retirement he yo
he really not in the building like he
sent out a
tweet one thing I will say is it is
weird that he's leaving and like there's
no thought process at all about a
successor like it does feel like and
let's get to adct let's get to it if you
look at if you look at like when cuz
obviously the the ladder Situation's
different than when it came to you know
Shan and you know Jack Trenton and stuff
but to me it feel was
like why now it's it this
early why if he's leaving a marsh why it
would make more sense to hold on to that
information until you get to March or
closer to that date when you have a
successor MH but to
me it's either Jim wants out now or they
want Jim out now oh so you think it's
it's nefarious you think I I don't know
like all I know is it's ironically and
it might be a coincidence that he's
leaving right after the ABK deal would
be finalized at that point are you
implying because of his lack of success
of getting the ABK deal block that this
led potentially to his demise if he is
being pushed out I don't think it's one
or two thing like I think it's a variety
of things you know we've seen with days
gone days gone sold well it deserved a
sequel from Sals why didn't PlayStation
give that one because they care more
about their reputation than they care
about Sals to a
point so when you look at this like look
Jim Ryan has made them a lot of money
but seen with games they care more about
their reputation if not more on the same
terms as they care about money and what
has Jim Ryan done since he's took over
he has had to shut Studios down he's had
to defund Studios because it didn't work
out well look what just happened with
the kns of the Old Republic we don't
even know if that game's still green lit
it's gone he's converted their the what
made the studios what made PlayStation's
identity identity what we don't know if
any of those are games are coming out
they're all games as a service
now he he made us wait for two years for
a showcase and gave us nothing for it
that showcase was not not good I give
you that clearly there there's some kind
of issue when it comes to developing
because where are their games oh my God
PlayStation has no problem showing you
something that comes out six years from
now now but you know what that's a
different PlayStation what's coming out
next year King that was Shawn leighton's
PlayStation oh man so you mean you mean
young man had somebody Spade hand and
they told him don't mess up the game and
they left and came back and he lost the
game he had a winning Spade hand and
threw in his hand and and then and then
you got to look at it from this
perspective too contain obviously
obviously this isn't Shawn leighton's
fault but in his Reign he's allowed
Microsoft to buy Bethesda he's allowed
Microsoft to buy ABK he's allowed
Microsoft to take multiple key component
Str uh Studios out out of of commission
look is that Shan Lane's fault uh is
that uh Jim ry's fault no but do you not
think the executives care no when we
when you took over the landscape was
different now why are we losing Call of
Duty next year so the shareholders is so
basically just I just want to be clear
he do you feel either him or the
shareholders was a mission to stop the
ABK cuz when the news came
out the real G ran D said oh oh we a
worry about that right we we we got
Bungie we he was popping off so then so
now that the the stuff came out with
Lulu and then he was like saying like we
don't care what we going to do we going
to block this deal so who do you think
do you think it was his mission to block
it he did oh God he didn't do it or the
sh like what cuz I see you kind of going
here you're hinting about this adkf feel
I think it could have went either way
but I am leaning more towards Jim Ryan
you know they've they're losing faith in
Jim Ryan that's what I feel because yeah
it's like said it's it's not a
coincidence right after this event uh
with with the ABK now he's talking about
leaving you know and let's be real here
a lot of his
Heights was approved in green lit by
Shawn
lady because after a couple what you're
saying here is uh Jim was working off
the coils of old old Sean
right so when the cool went down uh Jim
was the ring lad you're say yes Jim was
the ring linger and you know it's not
that he didn't make them money he made
them a lot of money he made them a lot
of money at the end of the day it's like
we said with the game portion that's how
they feel about the games but he didn't
take termites if that's how they feel
about the games that's how they got to
feel about their overall company and
sure you make me x amount of money but
what else do you seen core PlayStation
people like Jack bu Johnny Persona um
you know uh Jabari they're saying more
negative stuff about PlayStation than
good these days they're going on there
saying I don't agree with this decision
I don't agree with that decision and
they still love the brand and they're
willing to to sit by it but you're
seeing more of this happen and and you
know I I'm seeing it when God of War
Ragnarok came out I I saw a lot of
tweets like you know I love this game
it's a good game but I'm kind of getting
drawn out when it comes to this style
gameplay oh cuz it's like DLC you
saying no it's not like okay well yes
yes when we called Jim over to the
office we said Jim uh we need you to
have a seat now you know we've been
noticing the numbers are good but
something don't look right in the light
Jim something don't look right in the
light now um it come to my attention
that you were the one that started all
this mess now we had a good deal over
there with Microsoft and you took it
upon yourself to say that no you wanted
to kill the Dale in its entirety now we
told you sir if the deal doesn't get
done you know what happen
son don't now uh as of 40 455 today yes
your key what happened at 455 today your
key card would not work in this
building okay he's been he's revoked
access and and and listen we don't have
any plan on who to put inside your place
but we'll find somebody in this
building building but we need somebody
that play video games because obviously
what has happened to the PlayStation
brand is that guy that was in charge
didn't play video game you feel his
controller game rid the
gy well you know we'll be taking over
and effectively Monday we're going to
kill all games of services we won't have
any games coming out we will rely on
Indies we will take it
back uh cancel the PlayStation uh VR
that's a a Cess pool of money being
thrown in the bushes uh that's not
happening and the portal the Portal's
done we gonna cancel that right we
already know it's dead on Dead on
Arrival we're not there's people that's
already pre-ordered the portal that's
nice we're gonna we're going to keep
their money because we know that they
like the
Patron our stuff so we don't give any
refunds but we do like the fact that you
did pre-order but it won't be you're GNA
get it like the initial people are going
to get the ones they've already made and
then there's just never going to be any
updates on it it's like well you bought
it you got it but we're not not going to
sh at all keep the
money all right I got to sh [__] down he
out s has been patient s has been very
patient we tried to keep it together on
the side of balance and reason um s your
thoughts Jim Ryan uh no longer the uh
head of PlayStation and and your
thoughts on just all of this stuff
that's going on I just had I had to mute
because I'd be coughing too
much um it's it's funny that y'all you
know yes I knew y'all were gonna take
this out with they knew you was gonna do
this do this we knew we do but at the
end of the day I think y'all were the
first ones to say and y'all not were
wrong saying
that this is the path that had to be
walked talk to had to be walked somebody
had to do it because otherwise the
alternative was don't pivot correct
don't react to What Microsoft's doing
and be even worse
off right and really really be in the
bind and maybe yeah you're pleasing the
PlayStation faithful right you're giving
them exactly what they wanted games not
coming to PC true exclusive
it a like that and you're really really
when you look at the landscape look at
what Microsoft's doing not trying to do
anymore doing and that's a problem so
you needed somebody in that position who
was going to go in cold cold not care
handle the business aspect of it take
those shots cuz the shots were coming
and then in his attempt try to those
shots was that Phil Dominus Maximus
really expensive Mo most of it was
coming from there it was coming from
Phil right so I think Phil hit a and
they were and they were also it was also
coming from the PlayStation faithful
right the ones that were like what is
going on here what is all this stuff
that's happening double agent and so you
needed somebody there that was not going
to care about all of that stuff playing
games and was going to try to put them
in a position to compete where they
could they were never able they were
never going to be able to compete with
Microsoft monetarily right so the idea
say money funny compared to Microsoft
everybody's money funny so you know the
idea that you know him it was he was
never going to block the ABK deal he was
out there to be an agitator and it
happened and if it so happened so he was
a sacrificial lamb you saying who
P I actually disagree I I truly can do
real quick I I truly believe Jim thought
he could block that deal you thought he
went rogue did he he went Rog I I think
he pushed the higher ups to believe he
can block that this is the thing if you
say you say that right you say that but
Jim's a smart businessman right if
you're a smart businessman and you
really your aim is to really really do
everything you can to block that deal he
said that to Lulu there is no way no no
I'm saying but if your aim is really
really like I'm going to block this deal
I don't want I no he said I don't want
your deal I want to block this
deal in your heart of hearts if you
really believe that a you work hand
inand with the FTC and make sure and you
we don't
know he snitching snitching and saying
all typ of wild
stuff stupid ass every every week we
heard this man in a different country
trying to talk to about the uh
C the same time at the same time if you
go there and you drop these bombs you
snitch right
right if if you don't caress them and
and show them how to argue this in a way
that makes sense what good are you what
good is snitching doing you basically
you snitched to people who then took the
argument and then came to court with the
stupidest reasons possible why this
shouldn't happen it should never have
argued in the way that it was argued and
maybe we would have seen a different a
different outcome right he's new to the
snitch but but we got but so we got to
admit we have to admit we hind size 2020
but remember the whole I hate to call it
cuz the the the flying the dance moov
flying Ry it started because we heard he
was going to Brussels or whatever it was
right then we got to admit at the time
everything that the Regulators was
saying would seemed like it was
regurgitated from Jim's mouth Jim mouth
and and we have to admit the FTC and the
CMA block this thing look dead in the
water it looked completely like
everything was on his side and if it and
let's be honest only King was out there
hold the line that's how hold the line
start I was on some I was on some I
think this is over but I'm okay whatever
Direction leads to this being over I'm
going to go that direction hold the line
was King's moment because it looked
almost
impossible for Xbox to turn this thing
off like like prominent people saw guar
in the legal experts saying there's no
way I'm tweeting right behind him saying
shut up you don't know what you're
talking about right and and and and the
only slither of hope that happened cuz
that was right around the time when Phil
had to go to the game awards after the
block and en join and the only thing
that was Hope was you got to say let's
see what happened with the EU but the
percentages are so slim so we got to say
that in in addict's defense did he had
the boot on the neck and this thing
looked like a done deal before this
magical turn around happened it's like
he he was choking the life out of the
deal and right before they inspired he
just let go he thought he was done he
thought it was over started walking back
with his hands in the air it's over and
and then you see you see that Xbox logo
just get up it's it's more like uh Julio
cavez melc Taylor yeah getting beat for
whole y yeah yeah we was being beat and
I was telling y'all hey man calm down
stop you know hold the line you idiot
for holding line then now you had to go
back
and line okay so if you didn't learn
from there right came right back to it
and I told you Jim was gone in the next
fiscal period said that he's leaving
when period Right End fiscal period
right do you think that they're making
him uh if he is being forced out that
they want to do it now because they want
those investors this is the thing I
don't I don't believe listen I will
concede the point that he yes all right
he was all in shut it down had I don't
think this causes him to be pushed out
at all it down bring it down like I
don't at the end of the day real in real
hold on real quick I want to I want to
put something on when you are we're not
talking about the ABK deal we're talking
about Studios being shut down we're
talking about the lack of our first
party cuz let's be real screen it's been
keeping the PlayStation 5
afloat let me tell let me ask you let me
ask you what what a studio Japan done of
lately oh man yo it's down it's it's it
it doesn't exist it doesn't right what
what before it got shut down what what
what thing of note they do at that time
even though that they W even even though
they weren't delivering they still had
other things you done for me lately what
have you done for me lately time
PlayStation had stuff for them all I'm
saying is this there were business there
were tough business decisions that had
to be made put the business guy there to
do that right okay here's the thing s
the reason I'm pushing back on this let
y let him talk let him talk we got to
let him talk we got we interrupted we
been interrupt all of us interrupted s
yeah we're so mad with s but he trying
to real us no no I'm not mad with S no
we not mad with it but it's funny let
him cook let him cook ass off C us off
so I just don't get this the man and
with within their Silo he still managed
to launch a console in the middle of Co
facts that had no
stock and then when you had the
opportunity to have people who would buy
your console didn't have didn't have the
console to buy they didn't go over to
the other side they waited and they
bought your console MPD once the stock
was up was
crazy and he and he introduced he
introduced and then he and what did he
do he introduced what they needed what
they needed to even remotely try to
compare with what Microsoft is
doing and it's still right so he's gonna
walk out before he knows if that's if
that's successful hey hey whatever yeah
don't know listen if you have an
opportunity to write your own exit
ticket hey do you want to take that
smoke or do you want to walk off with
into the sunset with the w right hey I
left it in a good enough place see this
is another thing that gets me about
y'all all all these
metrics you cannot compare what
Microsoft does to them anymore there's
no metric like right but you can't but
but you are every single moment you say
I'm telling you is you talking about
they so so many into Co and these guys
got them all it doesn't matter who got
them it doesn't matter who got them are
they sitting on the store shelf no not
in customer hands and the reason why I
have to agree on that it they sold it to
some people it doesn't matter who it
doesn't matter if they bought them and
then they dumped them in the river 5
minutes later it don't matter they was
sold oh man that's the V oh man so okay
with that logic with that logic that's a
terrible logic because they need to sell
games they make money off of software
not hardare so you're telling me they're
selling at a loss to people that's never
going to boot up and never going to buy
a game this is the reason why they
facing mortality in your estimation how
many are sitting in the warehouse I got
all of them all of them is in the
warehouse number give me
number give me a number give me a number
because I got if you subtract that
number from whatever's out there it's
still out selling Xbox 3 to one so the
number that's in the I guarantee the
money don't math where how come they so
close money don't math they close in the
dollars it look like Sony's in the trail
and Microsoft is in front this goes back
to my point Microsoft has made it so you
can't make comparisons they don't show
they don't show own
metrics all right so what you do when
you when your metrics don't equal the
other dude's metrics you some hypothe
it's not even it's hypothetical
Microsoft metrics you can't he kind
right sucks he kind right they literally
created an algorithm created an
algorithm that doesn't exist outside of
their CU it just be about how many
played and how
exactly cuz you know what when you know
that your people brought and turned
their consoles on
and dud conses AR on you point to our
you know our engagement we have people
that's actually playing if you seeo
ain't even playing how the hell you
gonna expect other people outside to
play I will say this so in conclusion
get your bars off get your bars off let
them know got something to say after you
finish no really
I chance to say this part
you listen was Jim a meme yes absolutely
was he a meme did he try when he could
to try to come off like he played at all
yes that controller thater is hilarious
end of the day he was the right person
at the right time for what needed to be
done all of that stuff is in place now D
and it is destruction it is destructive
we go back to Peter Moore we go back to
Peter he did blow it up we go we go back
to Peter Mo plan right well this is a
plan that was placed upon them right
know they would have been more than
happy to keep the status quo if
Microsoft hadn't pivoted right if
Microsoft doesn't pivot we're not having
this conversation it's a different
conversation W would have gone to police
this would have never
happened shout out to Woody wer shout
out to woodyer so at the end of the day
he did what he needed to do during his
tenure there it is going to be on the
next person good as
Phil it's not you're measured by your
contemporaries sir he makes the money
that's what they care about they
obviously they don't care if you're the
most successful made the money he took
the door he just not giving the door
think the no no
no you know how you a sick and tired of
somebody and you tell them listen clock
out I I don't even clock out listen I
don't know who's gonna cover your shift
but get out of here that's what okay
so right you don't know who's gonna
cover this dude Calvin Schiff but you
was like Calvin get out of here you done
drove me nuts this is the last time but
I I will say this because ABK is going
through because
obviously Microsoft Microsoft strength
is going to start to show itself even
more now I could see him being like it's
time for me to walk I I don't want this
smoke I don't want this smoke they're
gonna lose that Revenue that they were
counting on and that's going that's
funding Microsoft now s was telling me
he looked at the closet saw the smokes
so
that's this right here I'mma leave this
I'mma leave it that's the thing right
it's all how you frame it I'm leaving
I'm leaving you in a good place what
y'all do with it that is on your you
know what I think I think the I I think
the mechanics in the basement saw the
fire and they tell the higher ups and
they got him out of there that's what I
think I don't I don't believe that I
just I just want to say this right
because nobody's brought up this point
he's not a good
leader all right you destroyed exactly
where the band the the the brand home
base was he needed to no listen you
disagree that he let me just finish let
me
just you destroy that you destroyed that
identity to that and you transferred it
to someplace else that's cool whatever
you feel that you need to do that fine M
anytime a studio messed up you threw him
under the
bus anytime something went down it was
somebody's other fault me and mly cool
is still kicking around they should have
been gone listen a lot of things a lot
of things when stuff happens Phil not
Phil's fault takes the hit that builds a
type of of camaraderie a type of a sense
of pride in the
company now if they send a a backo email
out to everybody what do you feel about
Jim and if you feel like he don't got my
back I'm on uh eggshells over
here um anytime something comes up is
like it's their fault you're not
supposed to throw a company and that was
Ben Ben when Ben took to Twitter to
explain they got ceas and assist shut up
stop talking about it my thing is I
didn't think that he was a good leader
with morale wise right and and this is
why I was saying yeah he's great for
Sony but what he did was he put them at
a loss he's not leaving on a high in
your head you're saying oh he's at a
record high here right but he saw down
the road the stuff that I did today
they're going to be tore up in six
months but get out of here now whoever
whoever comes in you think they're going
to blow up what he did no they're not I
think PC game I think um I think the
games go to PC day and date that is not
the person who's coming in is going to
follow through on his vision until it
works or it fails and then and then and
then they will move forward you're not
gonna come in and just change everything
this man put into place over the past
four it's not gonna happen I think that
will prove who what part of this
argument was right it's like because
it's if someone comes in and starts
blowing up the kitchen
because they like the way the kitchen
was made the the last couple years and
start rebuilding it then clearly he he
he was asked to leave I will and if they
and if they start following his line and
doing what he what he's been doing then
he left on his own yeah I would say this
I do think it behooves them to bring in
somebody who games who has the ability
to be more of a
face and and fill in that role and not
just be Mr businessman I don't care
about nothing who took over like
inter
heroi yeah but he's more Sony more than
that's what was interesting to me you
meaned to tell me so they have no sarbon
over there that they that they've been
grooming or anything like that like they
have no one to to take his place like no
one from the PlayStation brand was able
to take his place in any way shap we
have a pilot on the ship but we've
beening this we've been saying this
forever right how don't have a face
right if you think about it all the
things that he's had to do would you
want to be the face would you would you
want to be the face and there there's a
lot of smoke so you you let the dude who
doesn't really care about gaming take
the smoke or do you take because the
thing is the brand what what the
faithful expect from the brand was
always going to be tainted by the things
he had to
do always going to it was always going
100% but this is but this is this is
partly of his own doing right this he
came in he said look Sean the thing is
sha leaden told you already he told you
he walked out he is not sustain the
things that we've been doing till now we
reached the point where it is not
sustainable so something has to change
he didn't say hey I'm walking away
because may maybe in his heart and his
mind he's like I can't do the things I I
used to be able to do here it's not
going to be the same I don't want to be
a part of it cool I'm out they still
have shoe there that they could take his
place right now even if it wasn't like
permanent like my thing is like you have
people you have Shu there that used to
be part of that that whole engine years
ago you had they there's no way that
they have no one for the PlayStation
division all of that they couldn't step
up and take that position even if it's
just an intern but they brought someone
from another whole department well they
brought the the big bosses overseeing it
overseeing it until they find somebody
yeah until they find somebody you bring
the big bosses when the ship's on Fire
King like no the big bosses the big
bosses are are there to ensure the
business continues see we care about
that stuff we care about oh the face all
that yay they care about the bottom line
they care about the bottom line bottom
line had to go and like I said I think
it would behoove them to bring somebody
in who understands games more can
interface more with the fans who plays
games how bring up a menu and a start
button absolutely
absolutely somebody who doesn't answer
questions like I'm playing the next
greatest uh son first party game blah
blah blah blah yeah so I mean again but
I think the man did what he needed to do
in this time frame and we'll see if it
pans out it may blow up it may blow up
we got to see we gotta see but I think
he needed to do and it was a painful
transition it was you know hey you're
paying me $10 for these upgrades hey you
know um the price of this thing is going
up and hey your games are going to PC
yeah facts no facts but at the same time
he said we believe in Generations
exactly let let me jump in when oh sorry
if you got your boss no no that's it I
mean again he just he tried but he's a
business dude and he would have been
happy to just H you know have his head
down in the papers in the books and not
have to look at anybody in the face but
that wasn't the
case so when there's no PlayStation 6
you going to say that they set him up
you get your vs you get your flowers if
he is leaving I would say that that
might be one of the key components if he
left because of uh you know the family
thing he wants to spend more time with
family and people like oh he's too young
to retire these kind of people they can
retire anytime they want to they do it
because they want to do it they they
they got the money to go away in the
sunset and never be seen again but they
enjoy working and you know if if if the
if the flights and stuff was truly you
know putting a lot of pressure on family
then it's like yeah you know definitely
take a take a step back and get stuff
you done it's just some things just
don't connect the dots right with me
that's all yeah Co I'm sorry one more
thing before I passed it to you um so in
closing in closing with this vacancy oh
there
are potential candidates
who so you know this is the ha haa one
which is you f luminous out there
Lin Harrison I approve that
iove his track record hasn't been good
lately I don't know and and and there's
someone else out there who enjoys new
challenges
oh turn oh we doing that and you hey you
never know wait wait wait wait we
doing the the the the challenge of bre
someone who is not afraid to be in the
middle of a transformative movement oh
no that is not
popular are you implying our former gu%
implying a recent guest if you pull this
off and pet go over there listen
man you know how to
recruit you know how to rec p is
lit k k your Ki turn his camera off you
ain't feeling that yo I mean that' be
dope but you know he would get over
there and there just be another
Dreamcast I I don't think I don't think
he ever want to approach anything like
that I think you know he's a very shrewd
guy and understands what stuff the would
never make it in the marketplace he goes
to places to make him better um that's
no your estimation this place is in the
drags then this is perfect man I said no
I said they got wood
and that tree ain't going to grow it
ain't going to grow yeah it's pretty
much done oh man so that's your can no
Bobby that's it that's it oh actually
Bob that would just bobob available
Bobby will be available pretty soon but
you know golden parachute he might you
know he take that bread and chill hell
yeah might he might chill but again you
know an opportunity to stick it to to
activis in Microsoft sure I see that
that'd be funny and Sony for messing up
everything hilarious y so somebody yo
somebody just text me say some just gave
me a nightmare
scenario I ain't GNA blow up the person
who just text me but that was hilarious
look let me let me get in here
um I got to bring corporate [__] out we
got to bring him out we're going to
debut him today
look if you look at his run it's the
Winds of Change that's how I look at
he's the season of The Winds of Change
you know I gotta start with the good
first
pure dominance in Europe pure dominance
this is during the p PS4 era that led to
me to his rise you know to become the
head um when he becomes the head now
again we got to give him this like you
said s like during coid right when they
weren't able to get the units out and
stuff like that tas's point people
waited people waited for that PS5 and
then once the availability was there
regardless to
whom has it right they sold right and
they dominate they're doing as best as
they've ever done as far as moving
PlayStation consoles that's a fact so we
got that now to the other point which is
ushering in the PC ports getting the
money on the back end a resistant base
that doesn't want their stuff on another
platform so you ease them in the one
year lateer oh no it's not coming we saw
it we saw it slowly them talking about
mobile them talking about Cloud them
talking about live service this base is
is very resistant to this kind of talk
he had to usher that error in that's a
big deal and then the thing that I I
think is his greatest of a treatement is
that he brought that brand success like
in terms of like we we don't go to gay
magazines we go to GQ we we we are these
games should be bigger than what we you
know we selling right now the king's I
agree I think that King is right in
terms of he was not happy that their
Blockbuster stuff was not doing like
what the Call of Duty numbers and stuff
like that should do he feel these things
should be better now also a lot of
Acquisitions King's favorite he he
acquired your nixes you know what I'm
saying you know he got Bungie which I
thought was a good retaliatory move once
you know call I mean the ABK thing maybe
you got the E it could be it could be it
could very I'll give you that now this
is where the bad
is he really disconnected with the
hardcore PlayStation base the H tore
PlayStation B did not D that count
platinums yeah yeah those those guys
yeah them guys so to me another thing
that he doesn't get I say blame for but
I understand from a business standpoint
you have to Pivot from Japan to Europe
where the money's at that's what really
won PS4 like they dominate Xbox in
Europe like but in doing so you lose the
Japanese sensibilities because obviously
remember I don't know if you remember s
you know how their controler
configuration is one of the things
historic is like the button X in circle
right so X for us is usually confirmed
you know how it was K when you get the
Japanese console but Circle over there
and I remember when he came into power
that immediately changed and I remember
the hardcore Japanese PlayStation fan
was Furious like that was a sensibility
that like yo what are we doing we're
changing identity to be a more Western
you know what I'm saying kind of thing
so that was a huge thing um didn't
really interact with the base but you
can make the argument okay whatever he's
doing didn't have Community T night no
no you saw lack of shows lack of
communication yeah like they really pull
back you see the pullback from the E3
they're really not as communitive and
then the gaps between what's happening
like you really don't know now for me
too many
remakes it start to get oversaturated
you know what I'm saying as far that a
lot of redundant money grabs and we got
to be real now a lot of people always
want to come F Phil and oh you know
don't trust him and this that and the
third fine you can disagree with some of
his moves or whatever but when they talk
about straight lying to the base we
believe in
Generations we can't survive without
Call of Duty when when they caught you
on tape before saying that when they
caught him on table before say oh yeah
we ain't worried about that we ain't
worried about what they like that like
we got to we have to we have to be real
with that like and then you know tell
Lulu the whole we going to block the
deal you know the other thing is
actually the nickel and diamond right we
start during his era oh we ain't got no
smart delivery but for $30 B got the
money though right the Nicola diamond
for all these little things like yo you
going to pay for um oh you going go
Shima PS5 or here's this $10 and his
this $30 and it it's made it easy
though he did that also again good
business but hardcore sensibilities and
and over like remember the price raise
up for the for the console yeah it did
go from 60 to $70 the $70 for the games
yeah the we got a
war the PlayStation Plus price increase
and then the stop of reporting of the
numbers so this is my thing it it's they
are the most
successful and he made like sof made the
changes that needed to happen to a base
that was resistant and from a cold
business standpoint he did what he was
supposed to do to your point King the
future the jury still out on a lot of
these moves whereas are your live
Services really going to be popped you
got 10 of these bungees over there
supposed to help they just cancel the
fact we don't know what cancel but told
factions need to go back to the Drone
bro we don't know what's going on with
factions anymore now right then you know
10 live service games again the the the
the way the nature of these games
are nine times a 10 all 10 of them are
not going to be begging or successful
you could baby's going to be boo boo it
could be you know and for a Playstation
base that's used to a high bar of
quality right and you get some type of
games that might not hit that 90
Metacritic that you know it we got to
see that's
them that's them playing in an area they
not they're supposed to though I like
the pivot CU you have to you can't just
be hash just one everything right you
can't do that because at the end of the
day now what happens though I was
popping and locking they they don't do
that no
more but my thing is cuz now we're
hearing about the Horizon com forbidden
West complete edition like we're getting
to the point where we're remaking the
Remake you know what I'm saying kind of
for the PC though no no but I mean yeah
you're right it's coming for the PC we
going to re-release it for everybody
else but I mean the PC though the PC
need it look all I'm saying is a lot of
this stuff we have to see now that he's
gone if the live server stuff work out
if the mobile stuff work out if the
clouds like a lot of this stuff we just
don't know and the studios and stuff
that he picked what about the games he
chose right yes I just want to ask one
question yes please if uh what if those
gains don't hit what happens right
that's on that's on his watch that that
that's I mean what happens to the
company I mean because the company is
they made the pivot right they made the
pivot unsuccessful triple games right
and they said okay listen we going to
leave that stuff alone we going to make
these games a
service they they don't know they don't
have an experience with but that's bu
they got bung so but that's 10 games
don't Bungie have to get their game out
the door too and don't they have to
worry about their live service game yeah
absolutely oh that's a lot of work
that's a lot I mean hey they got that
that's what they they took the big budy
for they signed up to overse the live
service over there so that's on them I
don't know the future I can't predict
the future of them games if they going
to be good I think bu
I mean well that's your prediction I
mean you've been on fire you said Jim
gonna leave and that's happened listen
that was the first one say Bungie
leaving they out of here yeah I mean
it's it's look there is no question me
being a hardcore Destiny fan this is
being objective no family stuff there is
no question that Destiny is in its worst
state since they've been acquired I'm
not it's been the most bug written it
it's been bad now when I have these
conversations on the last teally oh
technically it is its worse and and it's
very money hungry aggressive right now
right so the thought process and I've
had this conversation with Travis and I
was actually I got to give Travis from
my his flowers is that his concern was
he used the term brain drain where you
are being your in your your knowledge is
being siphoned and because your focus
has to I remember you guys fought over
that we fought over that and I have to
give him that in the sense that if I
look at it objectively Destiny's quality
has been completely down yeah and the
focus may be because they're over there
to your point solving King if Bungie is
still in this thing where they have to
go to Naughty Dog see what they doing
they have to go to Every live service
and see what they're doing they're the
type that if they're not happy long term
they will leave and we've had hog on
this show and we looked at that contract
that signing he said I don't know why
Sony agreed to this bung has way too
much control way too much power they can
bounce
it was it was just everything in their
favor so I I can give you a situation
where that prediction maybe happens but
the opposite is it this is Bungie this
is Halo this is they know like if they
listen if Bungie went in the room and
told naughty dog nah bro y they told NY
dog that ain't it yeah that's power and
Sony said yep you tell
them you know what I'm saying so to me
part of it is a good sign because maybe
they do get a couple all they need is a
couple these joints to hit you know what
I'm saying so we'll see but I give you
this the jury is out on the decisions
that he's made and we just got to see
how it play out but yeah I mean short
turn that's all I pretty much all I got
we got any other and then obviously um
the only thing I was going to say real
quick was obviously we didn't talk
obviously last week was the um CMA a
preliminary approval to addict's point
you know if addict's theory is his goal
was to block the deal and he was
unsuccessful and to you know SS got
there the timing of your leaving and you
could you could you could leave
perceivably on top you know I don't know
you know this is just Theory speculation
type stuff but obviously you know they
can't be happy that Microsoft is going
to profit now once the ABK deal goes in
you know and have the marketing of that
so and then we got to say all this but
the FTC is looking the block still shout
out to L KH she's still outside she's
still with the taxpayers money doing
what she feels she has to do the Imp The
Impossible fight to the very end salute
to her but yeah this thing look like
it's going going down so that's pretty
much all I got any uh anything else will
we get into the Super chats npe right
cool okay hold on a second so super
chats and then got to pay the
bills hold on a second back here we got
a couple wow uh let me see we got the
angry therapist MD all that flying
around the world trying to stopped the
deal made him
retire basically then we have Lord
roughness 5 super chat I ain't trying to
hear early retirement travel
difficulties Jim was allowed to leave
before he got fired he was supposed to
stop the ABK de
okay here we got Lord roughness again
two chat Phil sent Bungie into
son there we got har chani $10 Super
Chat Jim lion snitching avk denying
crying games is a service trying price
ging crap show supplying no longer
flying forced it to retire and Ryan will
no longer generate the memes big hit to
all salt Sals
videos there we got Frank Castle $2
Super Chat yo is PlayStation hiring I
saw an opening
Wednesday and we got hardge chani once
again $5 Super Chat uh cute question for
the panel so with Jim Ryan leaving and
Xbox not making a pro do you think the
new CEO continues with the plan to
release a pro next year King
yes that thing is in production already
yeah it's next year understand shut
[Laughter]
up then we got some Jitsu Sage member
for 29 months Lord gold something is off
with Sony's numbers the console sold
aren't adding up with their software
sales or dropping ps+ Subs Sony's been
Channel stuffing uh ps5s uh gay pass
grew despite stock issues
I've said that long time ago well that's
the point game pass is supposed to grow
despite stock issues that's you don't
need a console no I wasn't talking about
that that last part I was talking about
the the numbers are looking funny in the
light oh my
Lord you gotta admit though King like
like you lost your Joker though this is
your he's this is your foil like you
lost your you don't know who they gonna
bring well I got every faith in the
world they're going to bring in somebody
that's going to do a whole lot worse
than this
and he still got to fix see this is the
difference between Phil Phil came in he
had to fix Donnie stuff right and
everybody was clowning him or whatever
ha the next dude comes in he has to fix
this guy's mess and everybody can
believe that there's no mess over there
I just hope that they give the next dude
all the leeway to work to see whatever
Vision it is through completion whatever
it is so if he goes in the first day he
says oh we're cutting off funding
towards the PlayStation y too please
rock with him y'all all right um if he
tells y'all he's going to raise the
games of services again to the highest
number rock with him rock with him games
of service games will be $99 rock with
him just just just give him a shot and
please buy games because none of y'all
are buying G you're messy thousand of
y'all in the chat y hit the like button
only 388 likes got a thousand of y'all
hit that like button those are all
PlayStation dudes they don't like
me that like but let's get these likes
up man hit that subscribe that subscribe
and that like while y'all up in there
thums down on that dude I don't like
him then we got then we got uh let me
see there we got Sage remember for 29
months little gold something is off on
these numbers the the oh yeah he put
this put yeah uh doc doc 50 $5 Super
Chat uh Jim Ryan tried to kill Xbox
forcing Xbox to start buying Publishers
don't Corner a trillion dollar
company knock your billion dollar
out
we there we got Tom from tunami $5 Super
Chat Jim was Jamal Adams when he got cut
from the Jets Jim tried to get into Sony
headquarters and said they didn't cut me
they did it's only been four
years
messy there we got Cowboys fan 404 $5
Super Chat in one week Jim Ryan leaves
Sony and Keith D gets arrested for the
murder of Tupac God is good if you keep
it yo you Wilding for that he said God
is good you Wilding for that
bro then we have towy $5 Super Chat Xbox
is finally ramping up with over 30
Studios Sony can't just turn the games
of the servers boat overnight they
absolutely will have a couple of years
like Xbox 2022 yeah that's what I worry
about they're G they're gon to they have
to that's all In Motion Discovery bro
it's all emotion now if they it be crazy
if they all hit but I doubt that'll
happen
then we got nintend deal taku $5 Super
Chat sales have nothing to do with Jim
Ryan PlayStation 5 was selling
regardless because of the brand he made
the necessary changes though the PC the
better sub well we always say this and
it's never true what yes you you
attribute it this is one of those things
that when you're at the head of a
company it gets attributed to you but at
the end of the day you didn't really do
anything right the same thing like you
know riding the wave of P same as for
Phil SP
not the cause of the the sales or
whatever so you know but you you do get
the recognition when you're the guy on
top same way you get the crap when it
goes sideways sure then we have Frank
Castle 20 Super Chat scalers
series scalper saw series X ands and
said we
[Laughter]
good then we have uh ous Stein with 5000
ugx I don't know what that is I will
look that up uh great show gentlemen
does King still think that there is no
ps6 yes oh he's standing on it oh he's
shoting he's emboldened y y'all should
have never let Jim leave now like that
just lends more Credence to what I just
told y y'all can't tell me what's coming
in 2025 y can't even tell me what's
coming in 2024 for stars
buddy we got Alvin $5 Super Chat the CMA
cave to fill and the next next morning
Jim found a dead koi fish on his pillow
is done with the snitching chair yo
sleep
story then we got Big Mad Mo member for
38 months Lord bronze Jim lion retiring
Ryan got pushed out no longer in charge
as of today shout out to the realm and
the Lord's here to here to more success
in the future salute salute what's up
punch out go
home then we got excuse God Emperor Sofa
King $5 Super Chat sa I would say uh
with the way games of service games are
going down the drain then Jim pivot to
games of server son is going to be in a
world of hurt in my opinion I mean I've
always felt it was a stupid pivot like
you don't pivot you don't pivot to some
Brent you had to because everybody's
doing it right and that's how if you're
GNA make money to support continuing to
make all these big AAA games that cost
$200 million you got to have something
that generates income on a month you
have to right so everybody thinks games
is a service at the same time you're
coming to a trend almost a decade late
basically and trying to jump on a wave
right and and and beyond that the people
who love and play these games only have
enough ban with to play one maybe two so
you're trying to make your way into this
space again I I get it because it's kind
of the format it's kind of the the
blueprint for what people are doing to
try to make money in this way but I I
don't see it being super successful I
don't see man if one of them hits even
remotely well it would be it would be
something so I I don't I'm not saying
it's a winning strategy I'm just saying
he pivoted to where everyone else is
pivoting
so we'll see we'll see let see Mr two
opinionated $2 Super Chat meanwhile
yoshita is in the Indie bushes yes yes
they they they relegated shu to the
Indies then we got let me see oh I got
roll back hold on a second then we have
uh THX 1138 $2 Super Chat uh so n y
Iceberg Dead
Ahead wow Iceberg yeah yeah it was crazy
uh long live the Black Mamba Super Chat
hash Hold the Line there will be no ps6
tell them King they standing on it with
King huh then we got Lord Ruff this two
pound Super Chat Peter goes over there
with the hammer and last
nail Peter versus
phille there we got Suicide Kings member
for 34 months Lord BR Jim Ryan said he'd
like to join the IOP podcast in March of
course he says he's got some Choice
words for one of
[Laughter]
you you are more than welcome to come to
the podcast let talk let's talk yes
let's talk please and we got the doctor
63 two Super Chat salute to I for 20K
thank you salute salute then we got
gamer McFly 2K uh $20 Super Chat thank
you you are amazing as well thank you so
much and we got Hot Grits 9105
super
yeah grits Jim saw that Xbox games road
map and said hell
no so Avalanche coming that's what we
doing okay yeah you not about that then
we got Raymond Morell $5 Super Chat I'll
never financially recover for this Jim
exotic wow
we are caught up pay the bills yes sir
pay the bills hopefully I don't yourself
cough yeah mute your mic peeps your mics
ladies and gentlemen I'm going through
it right now
bro oh excuse
me all
right support for the iron Lords podcast
is brought to you by manscape who is the
best in men's below the waist grooming
their product are Precision engineered
for your family jewels manscapes
performance package the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle join over 8 million men
worldwide who trust manscape with this
exclusive offer for you 20% off and free
worldwide shipping with the code iron
Lords at manscape.com if my math is
correct that's about 16 million
balls as the summer comes to an end and
fall is upon us the change in the
weather means we'll be putting away our
shorts our sandals our teeth t-shirts
and pulling out our jackets our sweaters
and our heavy pants and before Long
Winter will be knocking at our door
forcing us to wrap ourselves in heavy
coats scarves and snow boots now this
nippy weather may have you thinking to
yourself hey baby is car snow and my
Nethers can use all the warmth they can
get maybe I can go without shaving down
below for a while maybe the entire
winter season it'll be fine no one will
notice the smell the wife will still be
able to find the Gizzy and tater tots
I'm here to emphatically say no no no no
no at no point in time is it okay to go
un quaffed down below no matter what
1970s erotica may have to say about that
grooming and goodness thanks is he but
thanks to manscaped you don't have to
worry about that at all the performance
package 4.0 has arrived and oh man it is
a game changer inside this package
you'll find their lawn mower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop revor
toner performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold all of your goodies
so first off the lawnmower 4.0 this
trimmer is the future of grooming and
dare I say the greatest ball trimmer
ever the fal generation trimmer features
a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
Advanced Skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 is waterproof and also has
a 4,000 LED spotlight when you need a
more precise shave down there because
this trimmer is waterproof you can say
goodbye to the mess on a bathroom floor
as well you thought that was good but
want to take your grooming game even
further to the next level the
performance package 4.0 also includes
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer the weed Wacker is also
waterproof and provides proprietary skin
safe technology which helps reduce Nicks
snags tugs and those delicate nose holes
their crop preserver ball deodorant and
crop revor ball toner will change the
way you approach your hygiene routine
trust me when I say this fellas your
balls will thank you yes yes they will
absolutely they will manscaped even
threw in two free gifts to their
performance package 4.0 the manscape
boxers and the shed travel bag bring
your comfort and boxers to the next
level so it's time to take care of
yourself so go to manscape.com and get
20% off plus free shipping with code
iron Lords get 20% off and free shipping
with the code iron Lords manscape.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code iron Lords
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscaped a lot of Gizzy education make
sure that you get your packages right y
I was like this guy
here you know what that current to
American joint the Royal is
clear no he the Royal
thing yeah somebody said back to you sir
back to you s LS in the chat make sure
y'all use that cold iron L yeah make
sure that Gizzy right yeah get your situ
make sure your joysticks is right your
master sword is on
point and we good all right yeah and and
look out look out cuz they might there
might be some future improvements to uh
yeah some things coming things coming
out pipe pause pause seriously whoa that
was crazy you got you got the bushes out
there bro yeah that that was crazy that
was that was that was crazy that was
crazy so we going to move on we going to
move on that links links in the chat
links in the chat go check ambushes out
there it should be over now okay yeah it
take a little time a little delay but I
thank you for the the correction all
right so we are up what do we got what
do we got we got oh it's me we got a
little cyberpunk talk a little Cy Punk
talk we talk about the NZXT thing a
little more or we could we already done
that yeah we did that we did that so let
me let me get two actually two super
super Mingo MC Dickens $5 Super Chat Cog
how much beef would it take to get Jim
Ryan to mess up on him being fired give
him that good beef whoa we're counting
on you Village People Style I got to
give him the what's going on what's
Happening you kill me
[Laughter]
today there we got James thomas2 Super
Chat Jim took out his map and said
where's the
road yo that's wow then we got J Boy On
The Run $2 Super Chat did s say 16
million balls or bells or balls no it's
no not Bulls boss that's wow definitely
not Bulls wow that's wow that's super
pause that's super pause balls ball so
we good that's it we're CAU up I knew
that would do that no doubt no doubt so
look y'all uh cyber Punk man the uh what
you call it the Phantom Liberty
expansion is out with a shout out to CD
project red uh providing IP codes for
the latest expansi so we can take a look
and see what's going on just want to
quickly break down for those who've been
living under a rocket as far as what
feature set has been offered obviously
it's been the update 2.0 and the
expansion and the update 2.0 which is a
free update so redesigned skill trees
and perks revamped cyberware and new
capacity system vehicle combat and car
chases combat AI improvements new police
system UI and ux improvements loot item
and crafting changes new radio stations
including Community radio station growl
FM and then obviously we got the Phantom
Liberty that paid expens we got our man
Idris Ela AKA Stringer Bell for those
who know why doing this thing and uh dog
Town dangerous new District in the game
uh brand new storyline and characters
new Quest gigs boss fights and more
vehicle missions and airdrops endless
Dynamic events all New Relic Relic skill
tree and abilities 100 plus new items
weapons cyberware cars and fashion
vehicle missile launchers and the level
cap increase to 60 so this thing has
gone out it's getting you know fairly
positive reviews from what I'm seeing
most of it and I know we've played a bit
but uh I don't want to do the impression
I do want to take it a different
direction which is kind of like
obviously we know the history of cyber
Punk we've all seen this this is a game
you know at
launch the multiple consoles past
generation current generation
performance let's be honest pretty much
dragged um to the point that remember
this was a game that was delisted at one
point from the uh Playstation store so
with everything that's going on now and
obviously this is um an update as well
as nextg only and stuff like that for
those who played it whatever your
pressures are but is this the Redemption
Arc for cyber Punk so let's start with
Lord addict what are what are your
thoughts bear I think it is I think you
know they went back and they've done
enough
now the argument on should they be
forgiven for releasing the game in the
state it was that's a different argument
but I feel like they did go back and fix
the condition of their
game at least now if you guys still are
on this I ain't going to buy it because
I don't feel comfortable supporting the
type of practices that they did you know
releasing the game that was in that kind
of condition I I can feel that but as
far as like this DLC the patch 2.0 I do
feel like if cyberpunk would have came
out in this condition at launch then we
could really give them 100% props but I
can never really give them a 100% of
that it's like look you fixed something
that should have been fixed from day one
that's cool the game is a solid
experience and I'd recommend you guys go
play it uh but for me as myself I'm
still I'm still let half and half on
like recommending someone to because I
my thing is like
even though they went back and fixed it
it's like do me personally it's like
Lord adct cosigned telling people to buy
it when it's at that point where it's
like is does that reward bad behavior or
is that reward good behavior because
they fixed it or could you consider that
it should have been fixed from the start
so like you can't really reward good
behavior because it was because it
initiated and originated from bad
behavior I don't know uh but all I know
is cyber Punk is it's pretty fun like
it's it's a good game so you've been
feeling it um cuz you haven't played
since you kind of stayed away from it
I'm assuming but and then now with the
Phantom Liberty kind of going back oh I
haven't played it since week one oh wow
so you stayed away completely yeah I I
dropped it because it it it I had like
some some like gamebreaking issues but
it I didn't have as many issues as other
people but I did have some issues and I
just dropped it waiting for a patch and
then game came out another game came out
another game came out and then it just
completely forgot about it you know it
it's a fun experience it is U you know
you could talk about the I think more of
the moral guide where it's like do you
support this considering they released
it in the state they did especially like
last gen I don't know that's what for
you guys to decide right I feel like
Studios do deserve Second Chances and
but that's going to go from person to
person I feel that I feel that and quick
question because when you started uh
Phantom Liberty they give you the option
to start immediately from where the new
DLC is or do brand new with all the
update point to you know from the
beginning and then let it integrate
natur which way did you go I went start
brand new brand new okay yeah I didn't
play the base game so it would make no
sense for me to be like yo let me let me
jump in there in that Liberty like I
feel that fair enough fair enough Lord
Sovereign cyberpunk you know obviously
we know the history you know obviously
we know where they are right now seems
somewhat positive reviews on on Phantom
Liberty where you at with this whole
thing is has cyber Punk earned a
Redemption Arc for you yeah I think 100%
it has um you know regardless of how the
state that that game came out in the
devs the people that that work hard on
that game for years and years and years
knew full well that that game should not
be coming out and that decision was not
theirs to make right it was made by
people above them and they had to deal
with the Fallout of it had to deal with
all the BS and people blaming them and
pointing a finger at them and it's just
it's not really the way it is but at the
end of the day everybody has their
bosses everybody has their masters and
they say it's got to come out it's got
to come out and so and they dealt with
the Fallout of that and then continue to
work on the game now what this is three
years later this a 2020 game that came
out and they're still you know this is
going to be it for it right and and the
fact that they went in and basically
redid everything thing um and then in
addition to Phantom Liberty being
attached to it I just
think you have to you have to be you
it's a certain point in time you have to
say okay I'm gonna give this game a
chance now um I bought the game day one
every intention of playing it I bought
it on PC actually I bought it on Console
as well I had and uh and then you know
the stuff started coming out and because
of how bad the the conversation around
it was I was like you know what let me
let me just not
yeah yeah they want
to I want to be clear too that um we did
get review access to this they did say I
said that I said that transparent from
The Joint to let them know again shout
CD project hold on hold on we do got to
interrupt real quick shout out to one of
the biggest cyber Punk fans in the chat
our brother F zelli gaming brother we
love you rest in peace rest in peace to
you to to you to your dad and uh again
we put the link in the chat for anyone
who wants to support you know what I
mean it's as far as the the funeral and
then the services I'll put the link back
up in there but that's a good brother
man and F is one of the biggest cyber
Punk fans like his whole chatel like
even when he had the the intro on you so
had that kind of retro cetro Vibe man
and hopefully you know when things
settle down you get a chance to to game
and stuff but uh love you brother good
to see you up in here man we know we
know what you're going through and we
really we really want to empathize and
show our love of support to you yeah
continue so so
um so yeah I you know I haven't played a
lot of it I just I threw it on cuz I
wanted to see what these changes were
and to really see how really how it
could you know how it ran on this new pc
that we have um yeah again I I put the
NZXT budes MXT with NZXT in that player
three AMD Edition AMD you showing off
your build on that cyberpunk the way it
was supposed to be played the way adct
supposed to play it yeah absolutely this
is one of the games I bullied
on you're playing this on PC damn
it and it and it shows out it really
shows out it is so well optimized again
every every time I put in a new game I
turn off all sort of FSR I turn it all
all off just to see what the PC can do
and then if it's you know if it's like
hiccuping and having some issues then I
turn on some of the you know sh to flex
bring bring down the the resolution or
whatever um but no at 4K with with ra
tracing I didn't turn on path tracing
I'm gonna I'm gonna try that to see if
it buckles the computer that path
tracing but but full raid tracing at its
highest I have it on ultra settings
running beautifully at 60 this game this
game is still an absolute
showpiece this game running on on a PC
of that caliber with all the new bells
and whistles all the optimizations they
made to that game it is really something
to behold
M I'm sorry and it really I mean it's a
showpiece and the fact of the matter is
that everything that was wonky about the
game they went in and changed and they
redid and they say you know what don't
go in with your with your SPC out
character start a new game trust to
start a new game so I've only played a
couple of hours of it just to kind of
get the feel for it and uh yeah it's it
feels like it's going to be a special
experience obviously I was anticipating
this experience three years ago figure
out a time to play it but
um I don't know how it runs on a
rag but honestly okay you you'll talk
about that honestly though I kind of
want to I'm kind of being selfish I'm
like I don't want to play it on anything
other than the I'm be real you big boy
it's such a
showpiece that like don't get me wrong
if I'm on the go and I'm I'mma do it but
um that I I I'll talk about when it's my
turn but I yeah but I I know where
you're going I know where you're going
but but that was it though I haven't
played that much of it just enough to
see that it yeah they they've really
done the work so I think they deserve
the credit man you think about like a No
Man's guy they went in there and and
they they still to this day working on
that damn game um so you know they've
had like a a decade long Maya Copa yeah
um so to me when it comes to Deb's going
in and fixing a game and knowing that
the way the state the game came out and
affected their reputation immensely and
it kind of not being their fault um I'm
always going to give the devs benefit of
the doubt and this feels like it was
like obviously management realized what
it did to them yeah and and you know the
the devs are now getting the shine they
should have gotten instead of the IR
that they received um so I'm happy for
them I would say go out and buy this
game and you can find it it it went up
in price when Phantom Liberty came out
right because you could have found it
for 20 bucks the base game anyway for
you know weeks prior to that then all of
a sudden it jumps back up in price but
it's it's still 100% worth it cuz I
there aren't too many games that look
like this at all so yeah go out and get
it if you if you waited now is the time
yeah no absolutely AB I hear what you're
saying Lord King someone who's uh stayed
away I remember during the you know the
height of the drama it was it was
everywhere you know and you were pretty
staunch on that but um yeah now that you
Phantom Liberty's out you know am man's
is outside you know what I'm saying
string you know I'm saying know what I'm
saying one thing I I can say is you know
days in our time it was uh a bad game
shifts ships it's bad
forever this time now a game can ship
bad but turn good over a period of time
right looking at you Arcane get back to
redfall
um CD project red has been really good
at that you know if a game has problems
through patches through uh free patches
mind you they don't they don't charge
for the upgrade because these these
upgrades and stuff these DLCs now they
charge for this DLC which is a little
departure from what they would did with
the The Witcher but I think with the The
Witcher was more of a Mia Copa you know
for that this one they felt that they
had a good game and I think they was
pushed out by board to to reach
unexpected uh shipment goals and that
affected the overall um value of the
product because you know if it's a
diminished product going out it's going
to have a diminished value and I think
now it's it's it's at a higher value
with the the the Phantom uh DLC and
ildis and you being able to start the
game uh with all that in place uh from
base yeah they did a lot of quality of
life things um and if if you're part of
that world they gave you more yeah right
when unexpectedly that you didn't know
that you was going to get this more
that's not even the DLC part I'm just
talking about the free upate 2.0 is fire
on its own absolutely the game starts to
look like what they envisioned I hope it
has the no man Sky success because
Norman sky was ridiculed at launch uh
for not fulfilling whatever goals and
stuff that they set forth but now you
look at NORAD sky and you're like wow
this game went so far because of the
love and passion the developers that are
willing to go back in there and to
deliver on their promise so I'm never
going to say to a publisher right now
with an unrealistic goals of the board
is forcing you to do things but you're
still willing to stay there in the mud
and get out a game that you can say that
you're proud of so my hats off to you
guys the game is phenomenal and keep
grinding you know uh Excellence speaks
for itself a lot of companies don't do
it a lot of company leaves a broken game
a broken game and I think you know more
companies should back their product and
try to uh drop at what they initially
expected because cyber Punk was supposed
to be the game of a generation facts
right so for it to fall short of those
lofty expectations I mean and for them
to go back and work on it you just got
to take your hat off them yeah I'll jump
in I mean yeah this is a definitely feel
like a full circle kind of kind of Arc I
remember saw E3 I think this was I's
first meting when we went solo we went
back solo and it was E3 I think
2019 maybe I can't remember yes it was
2019 I had log Net's F that was log
Net's first big behind the scenes with
CD project red cyber Punk behind the
scenes showing for the first time then
me and you you interviewed me was me and
you asking me questions about the game
he was out there LA and we got that
joint remember that joint yeah that did
that did good for us that did good for
Lord that did great for us it's a Pity
that that wasn't G yeah it's pity that
it was on the highest end PC and it
wasn't representative of it was the best
vertical slice ever made but when I saw
it I was just like man this game has so
much potential and um yeah the kind of
the Kings Point to me the game looks so
phenomenal it's how I expected all of
Next Generation to look to me they set
the tone as far as the graphic now that
we know the story we know what happened
and it was disaster you know what I'm
saying um to me just way too many
platforms let's be honest past gen
should have been cut out and and they
you know probably maybe try to chase the
board think the biggest issue facts when
you trying to develop for base PS4 base
Xbox One and you had the new and let's
be honest this is they launched right in
that transition period where there's not
enough install base for the thing and
the Boardman say yo we need that and
you're pushing these developers to make
on this that's why I'm so happy with
Phantom Liberty the decision to cut past
gen was there it's only nextg and King
only
ssds if you coming in there with that
mechanical hard drive you can't play
that is a requirement for this joint and
the difference yeah the difference is
there you know one one thing I do want
to give them their um flowers is and a
lot of games are not doing this and CD
project I love yall for this is y' C y'
cloud crossplay is the greatest feature
I want this in every game you know once
you set it up once you you connect to
the CD project red site or whatever it
is and it now automatically puts your
saves in the cloud so I'm going from my
series X to my Series S then I jump on
my Ally have the game on Steam
continuing my save data data that's the
future of gaming to me and they kind of
pine I don't see other games really
doing this and that really change again
cuz now I'm boom on the plane you know
what I'm saying boom go back I could go
you know continue my say EX exactly
where I at love that joint um yeah I
think that the um the G oh I
got corporate Cog moving so when I
played cyberp Punk for the first time I
always did Street kid you know I'm
saying be for the streets you know what
I'm saying running around with Jackie
whatever whatever so this time I'm like
I got to assume my corporate C Persona
you know what I'm saying so I did corpo
for the first time on a new play through
yo the joint is drastically different
drastically the shess then then the boug
the way I entered the game was
completely different I was up at some
flying joint I had the liquor the wine I
had like all it was like I was in a
flying limo son it was crazy yo the
corporate Cog joint shout out to the
cops they agreed too they was loving it
but um yo dog town is amazing you know
what I'm saying it looks phenomenal you
could tell they really took their time
as far as just again the graphic
Fidelity the way the game plays all the
new changes but to Kings . 2.0 changes
the game the free update by itself and
the last thing I wanted to say I think
for me why I got to give them their
Redemption Arc this was the key moment
and adct remember this was cuz y'all
went the Lord we went to our first packs
together this year but the prior year
was my first packs West and I was out
there and they did reach out I mind you
the game was not in a not that it was in
a good space but nobody was talking
about it and I remember they were like
yo you know they're doing like a
screening for um some Edge Runners thing
anime and I was like what's this but I'm
like all right I got time let me check
it out I am not going to front that
anime was so good addict that it made me
want to play it again and at that time
they had I guess a patch 1.5 or whatever
it is that really addressed core issues
that everybody's like yo the game is
playable and then he had some EDG Runner
content in the game when Edge Runners
came out that made me want to play I
don't want to know where where Adam
smash at where I Ain like how you know
say like it was one of the best
synergies to kind of get you get people
back into the game and I got to get them
credit man it was really well done so
yeah I do think that um they've they've
they've have the conclusion part of the
Redemption Arc I think the game is
completely payable go check it out I
it's still one of the best looking games
I feel a generation still to this to
this day and uh yeah we got to support
Stringer Bell man it's all about you
know the wire right now
what he doing so what he doing so has
there been recent news with them did
they recently lay off a bunch of people
um that's a good question epic um what
team I know epic did I know epic did but
I think there was something because what
I worry about with them is that fall
guys uh they went through yeah that was
that was epic but this is this wasn't
this wasn't that recent it was a little
little earlier than that but I could
have sworn they let off some people from
the from the the The Witcher team the
the the guys that were making the it's
possible it's been so many layoffs yeah
but that's my worry with them right they
they saw the mistakes they made with
cyber Punk and then they went right back
and when they gave the roadm they're
like yeah we're making five Witcher
games and we're making this and we're
making that I'm like whoa whoa whoa just
one at a time take it slowly you know
what I'm saying they give you this whole
road map obviously they're not going to
work on all of them at the same time but
they did say that they were going to
work on certain certain uh different
titles uh simultaneously right right
right so it may be one of the like okay
what did you come up with in the ensuing
like last two years that makes you think
you can be that flexible you know so My
worry is that please learn your lesson
yes please yes the higher ups please do
not put the devs in this position
anymore let them let them make the game
that they they they set out to make and
give them the time to make it yeah um
and that's it because you don't want to
again people this is the Redemption Arc
now has people in a great place and you
talked about the the Netflix show yes
that also put people where they wanted
more
cyk it was so well done and then then
now you give them the actual game that
they wanted three years ago um and it's
like okay cool I'm I'm willing to to to
hear you out now don't mess that up but
absolutely a buggy mess or whatever the
next thing is that you're doing like no
absolutely absolutely I think it was it
is a teaching moment for them as the
studio it was a teaching moment for the
industry about rushing games and putting
things out and you're not ready and like
King said the board and whatever you you
got to learn you risk they risk damaging
their pristine brand reputation and name
at that time so it's so cool to see that
they stuck with it go ahead ad if
anything that shows these other
publishing developers like look like you
know they had a solid product but didn't
give it enough time to fully develop and
it's just like don't don't risk your
your your brand and and you know the the
trust of your consumers and your fans
just to make a quick buck because you
know it's like that's why I said like
it's hard for me everything in me wants
the coign 100% going out there redoing
the Cyber Punk stuff but then the other
part of me is like you know even though
it hurts the developers and I hate doing
that it's just
like there's no way you can can make a
statement against what they did with
that without hurting someone that isn't
isn't the crossfire but at the same time
Publishers know that
yeah I mean look it's it's I always feel
it's a moral choice and I feel like you
can sit there and say look I cannot
forgive a broken game they did that I
I'm sorry you're not getting my money
you know what I I I could respect that I
could understand that and then I can
also I just want to say this last point
I can also understand someone saying
look the decisions of a few shouldn't
affect all the developers who work super
hard on this game and maybe were put in
a position to do something that was
impossible so for me I lean more that
side because they say thousands of
people work on the game but this board
of five this corporate Board of five you
know what I'm saying made a dumb
decision that cost the potential
reputation in the game so I get it it's
a personal decision I feel you but I
guess like my mind is like I've been
very vocal about
companies producing less broken games
taking more time and I just I can't
shake it's like they fixed a game that
should have been like this for the start
so is as cool as it is right right
now and I do recommend playing if you
own it I can't REM I can't recommend you
going out and buying it because it's
just like that's way you because at the
same time it's
like then what like right now what's
going on with Battlefield 2042 what's
going on with Halo infinite like I feel
like going out and saying stuff like
that is going to be like okay you know
we can't can continue doing this because
we could just fix the games
later and it's just like the people
making the money
unfortunately that's not a lot you could
do about it because it's like you can
either support the game because there's
so many people working on it but then
when is the issue ever going to get
fixed because it's like even though they
fixed it three years later you paid $6
three years ago to play this game now
yeah you know what I I really do think
like the the big Catalyst for them to
really like turn around on it obviously
was not in great shape but a lot of
people on the PC didn't have a lot of
issues with it it was the console
versions obviously it was that D listing
from the PlayStation 4 yeah that was the
reputation hit so that was unprecedented
yeah I've never seen that that
really that was Jim Ryan went playing
that was that was Jim not playing with
that that you ain't messing up I'm not
giving you no money back B oh yeah they
wasn't do oh yeah cuz
PlayStation
forgot to them yeah so he would rather
take it off his
store and look out for the consumer he
said you know what you none of y'all can
buy this get this out of here now change
the key card on this
game I forgot about that yeah hey look
that's that I'm sorry so s speaking Yeah
it's like I said you know I love the
game you know it plays way more fluidly
the the combat's cleaner I'm rocking
around with Kat is like it's like
everything in me wants to be like green
light green light but then the other
part of he's like do we really reward
for Stuff fixing that they should have
already real what what about the
Counterpoint if they never fixed it and
just left it broken then obviously we
wouldn't even have this conversation at
all then we would be having this
conversation with The Witcher and not
this game right but my point is there's
no for you I'm just asking a question
about trying to argue with you
is there no what's the word it's not
forgiveness because that's not the word
it's like to Redemption yeah like there
there's no redemption in a way for you
because it's like if they to me a
Redemption would have been Phantom
Liberty
free that would have been Redemption for
me you know we that free update we we we
went above and beyond and we're going to
go ahead and and slide this to you free
of charge because of the condition that
the game was in at launch how many
people bought this on the PS4 and and
Xbox One like and the game was not even
functioning like it it didn't work at
all and and then we got to talk about
the the the sketchy way that they send
out review codes you know U you know
trying to silence people just talking
about their experience because some
people got it early it's just like it's
such a great area and then you could be
talking about all this and the people
responsible for all this they're all
gone so the the 2.0 update is free and I
do remember the um the the people there
was a lot of backlash because a lot of
people that reviewed it was reviewing
the PC version and then it was like a
shock you know kind of similar to refo
situation right when the when when the
when the console one came out we like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that kind
of thing so it is what it is but I get
someone said like how Ubisoft did with
the unity DLC giving the first free
instead of charging yeah it's like
sometimes when you mess up bad like it
it's like it's three years too fam like
this a this ain't six months later it's
three years took that law to fix that
that game was busted but so so do you
think do you think like I say they make
the right decision from the jump and
they they cancel those and they but the
game they hold the game till now you
think that's a scenario that would even
happened they that game would most
likely been but here's the thing what
what goes on behind closed doors and
their bottom line is not my concern what
my concern is in a consumer is getting a
functioning product at launch oh yeah
for sure I'm not saying said that they
should have did done what they did they
they they had to do this because they
had to repair their brand and D is a
repair brand I would say that they did
offer you the Cyber Punk expansion that
you did get that that I mean the Cyber
Punk game that they initially off to
give because if they didn't fix this and
put this out there then there would have
been a lot more side eyeing for The
Witcher and and it's just like look like
at the end of the day like it's it's
definitely one of those gray areas cuz
like said the people that could
literally have been responsible for the
reason the game came out those higher
ups they could all be gone but at the
end of the day should should CD project
red be punished for the people that left
that's my question that's that's my
question at the same time if we don't
hold the it's it's like when we do the
review things on IG we don't consider a
an individual writer we consider the
whole entity it don't matter how much
time goes by IGN reviewed that game IGN
gave it that score and it's to to me
it's like if we start playing semantics
on who was there and who wasn't there
then at that point you can throw that
with anything but it's not about it's
not about who wasn't there it's about
the people who are power to make
decisions though like we we can't blame
people who have no power what their
bosses are telling them what to do and
if they're not in agreement with it
we're going to blame them too I can't
that part no one's blaming them right
but you're but I'm saying no one blaming
them now now but at the time the whole
studio got dragged every single person
was CD project red and how could you do
this CD project red m at the same time
when you look at if are we supposed to
let the higher ups off then no I'm not
saying let anybody off I'm just saying
that there is a distinction between the
people who make the decisions and then
the people who make the game that's all
I'm saying that there there is a path to
hey I'm not going to punish the people
who are making the games if the bosses
were not making the right calls but once
again you not punishing them means that
the other side gets off scoff free no I
didn't I didn't I didn't pick up the
drink I stopped I was like I'm I'm good
until y'all get it together that's
exactly what I that's what king said I
was like this is not acceptable again
it's a personal decision right some
people said nope I'm good I'm playing it
I like it PC was fine me I'm like that
wasn't acceptable so I'm good when y'all
decide to come back around and get it
together and look like we're finally
here now then I'm like all right go
check y'all out but I I I I think you
can vote with your wallet and and not
support the behavior to your point right
cuz you're like yo don't support the
behavior and I think that's a okay
decision to make
yeah everybody
good okay sorry
like they could so something like this
we're clearly not gonna agree on so I'm
i'me with I'm not disagreeing with you
no Noe with everything that you're
saying I'm just saying that you know
some companies get a chance to have a
pathway to Redemption if the board is
forcing them they have no control over
that so so so uh adct in so in your
scenario like so that does your feelings
towards this translate to the next
Witcher like I'm not messing with you
here's the
thing I just don't like the way they
release the game at the end of the day I
just don't like it and you know me
coming out there and saying like you
have to earn that trust back now I do
like I said they had to release this to
earn that trust back if they didn't have
released this then I would be more and
and I don't even care about the wtcher
anyway so most likely I won't be playing
that but it's just I just don't like the
practice I don't like you know suits
going out there pushing games out there
to an audience that they know is broken
using you know very shady reviewing
tactics to make sure that people get the
the copies that work you know uh go it's
just I don't I don't like it and you
know and you and you support it by not
picking it up
right I yeah you didn't you didn't rock
with it right you your squ I'm not
talking about that I'm talk that's not
the debate the debate isn't then the
debate is should you buy now even when
they did that back then right and your
point is you're not rewarding anything
because even if it's a Redemption AR
that's where you at you're like I don't
like what happened from the beginning
I'm good you it's in a good place it's
too late that's where you at like I'm
not disagreeing with you like you
thinking I'm debating you I'm just
saying I'm just trying to understand
your point you're like even if the
developer they fix it and they do
whatever it doesn't matter because the
way y'all launched it the way yall did
that was shady and I'm good so and that
right and s's follow-up question to you
is because of that that makes you
question everything else moving forward
like if the new Witcher come out you
like yo I don't know because this what I
did with cyber pump is that correct it
puts me in the position where I'm like
with their games until I get a game or
two in it's not a day one it's just wait
and see like it's no pre-order kind of
thing it's like you you you you served
me a game that barely functioned you
don't get the right to demand my money
the next time going around that's fair
and and I totally that's why I said
always I always said this is a personal
decision right and when someone does
something like you you good like ain't
nothing wrong with that that's totally
fine by me so that's what I said we
ain't disagreeing I'm just listening to
your point
anyway we are we good everybody got the
the bars off mhm all right cool let's
get the uh super chats please none
okay moving on unless you want me to
repeat the balls one no n we good we
good we good we good let us know sir no
doubt no doubt anyway um let's get ad
you are up uh TGs man a lot of stuff
going on Tokyo game show what's going on
that's a a lot of good pretty good games
in there I actually enjoyed some of the
stuff the thing out I actually
personally uh I did live stream it so
people want to go and watch it I I I
live stream that um solid experience man
solid experience solid games you know
there was no Final Fantasy 7 remake
obviously and I think we all kind of
knew that was happening uh but you know
I actually enjoyed this more than I
enjoyed the state of player or the the
recent Nintendo
directs yeah it was it was decent what
was your what was your
highlights uh octopi travel 2 yeah big
one big one there was like a leak or
something that said that it was coming
to Game Pass but they took it away um
you know it I don't know if that was
just someone because here's my thing the
context of the situation the context of
the the sentencing they they put in
there they put it next to uh the Yakuza
game that's coming to Game Pass and to
me how do you mess up that bad where you
not only say something's coming to Game
Pass but you put another game that's
coming to game game pass with octopi
traveler 2 so it's just like if it was
just octopi traveler 2 and it was to
2024 I would okay that seems like a more
genu one mess up but how are you going
to form a sentence where it's saying one
and the other's coming and one is coming
to Game Pass how do you mess up to that
degree maybe they a little too early on
on yeah I feel like maybe there is some
negotiations on pricing or something
that's going on right now and that is
what you're seeing currently no doubt
Xbox TGs Sol did you get a chance to
watch any highlights
standouts oh yeah like adct said um it
was definitely you know seeing octopath
2 there right after we uh sort of were
wondering what the heck happened there
you know and uh after getting octopath
one so yeah that was cool to see that
was cool to see it's always I'm I'm
watching tzs to see where the forward
movement is right where the where where
are they sort of settling in Japan and
again they continue to impress in that
regard you know obviously the you know
both like a dragon games both coming to
Xbox um also the the the game that just
released which was infini stash that's
the worst name ever yeah that name is
weird it just cuz you could just place
the S on the Infinities and then it's
Infinity is trash so I don't understand
why you do that but whatever um yeah
nothing beyond that you know we got you
know obviously we knew Persona 3 reload
was coming and tactica you know you guys
got to play that
some wo long DLC so it's good to see
that those relationships were still sort
of you know continuing to grow um but we
didn't see anything like s apart from
octopath right we didn't see anything
they was like oh my God you know but the
mic drop the mic dropped moment but
again it it is one of those things well
you know what though I don't recall if
this is if this had seen its way to the
console before but the Ace Attorney
games yeah we're getting Phoenix right
the Ace Attorney Trilogy did it come to
Xbox before right did it come to game
did it come to Xbox period before cuz
the trilogy came out on like Nintendo
definitely Nintendo at least last year
if I'm not maybe I'm mistaken so this is
a first for that so if that is the case
that is that is big that is big and
they're also going to get the Apollo
Justice games as well so um yeah these
are games that are traditionally
Nintendo games making their way on to
console I know they making them so to be
on more platforms but the fact that hold
on the chat the chat is saying it's been
on Xbox before been on Xbox before okay
so then then my misspoke but um but it's
still cool to see that there the other
smaller stuff like the Ala Wrath
of um obviously you know Auden Chronicle
still being held up into next year um
wait did they say EU didn't I know I
know definitely that too right there's a
delay so yeah to see those things
continue to grow is just the important
thing right and then hopefully Make Way
for for mic drop moments in the future
but um yeah it was solid though it was
definitely solid no doubt King Xbox
Tokyo game show thoughts all right so
I'mma keep the same energy right oh yeah
because I thought you you thought you
were coming from oh I was ready ready
ready you weren't going to get me
sir all right so this is um David Lord
King David talking
um I love the fact that Microsoft was
out there I love the fact that Microsoft
continues to make inroads in uh foreign
territories to show that they're willing
to um capitulate to some of the things
that are the norm in other regions like
uh localization yes um that stuff is
necessary for you to grow your product
you can't ship a product in a region
that is not localized like that doesn't
make any sense nobody will look at your
product they don't understand your
product right so um that end worked well
for me octopath traveler to we was
thinking like why is it uh Missing the
platform when part one came out so that
gave an answer there and I think a lot
of stuff is like contractually wise they
can't talk about a thing because it will
hurt a product that's on a competing
platform and if you knew that that
product was coming out on your platform
you could just uh say I'mma sit back and
wait for it to reach my platform so um I
really think that uh that's good
now this is King
talking and and and Lord King David
would give that show a eight oh oh Lord
King give eight even with the
multi wow I remember we watching Sony
show and they show multiat and stuff
that existed but um this is King keeping
the same
energy I remember ad someone gave
someone so this is this King this is
King this is King keeping the same
energy that shows a zero okay
occupi traveler 2 ex already there was
actually no exclusives there no
exus there goes the show being a zero
sir could you hold down could you hold
on I'm speaking I'm speaking my truth
sir okay my
truth make sure to say it's my truth
when you got a chance to talk your truth
I didn't bother you I was quiet actually
I a church mouse
sir well anyway that's cuz you were
trying to decide how you're going to
f well I've successfully done that sir I
give the show a zero all right because
um you did not do what I thought you
should do I thought you should go out
there and um beat your chess in a region
that the compaion are no longer there
you know you take over their home
territory you you get in their abandoned
houses and you take over and you make
that your house take over they wasn't
there they took that uh region for
granted you always have opportunities to
stick the boot down their throat and I
know working in the backgrounds I know
there's stuff that's working on and you
can't say things yeah I know next march
you have a big announcement for that
region and for our region I understand
that but something grab something snag
something that you're trending for the
TGs not for the fact that you're signing
PlayStation covers that right there and
I'mma keep it a I understand in in in in
The Spoils of War you keep what you kill
right I know you kill it you was taking
a picture with the
B you know that the whole thing you want
to see a dead body yeah you so even even
a Final Fantasy 7 remake wouldn't have
done anything for you um no that would
have done something to me oh okay cuz
you that was to me because yeah it would
have gave it one point yeah it one point
I mean it was multi exist gave it a half
a
point because I want stuff that you want
that isn't over there I want exclusive
stuff I want your stuff first party
let's say you to drop High five Rush DLC
right oh let's go okay all right let's
oh meca Sal is coming oh oh my god let's
go or we got the exclusive right to a
new Godzilla game yo what
happening or or or Kingdom Hearts
something you want that home run that's
not there it wasn't there it was we are
here in the absence of others and we're
making uh inroads in this territory okay
and I I would love for you to be there
rather than be there so again like I
said Lord King David gave it an eight
King gave that a zero okay fair fact I
was coming I was waiting to see what you
was going to say had separate sep I was
like boy i' had to hear it myself some
state of play boy right yes yeah yeah
you know different and Dodge different
DOD absolutely listen rope do gives it
an eight add for C gives it a two
thankfully I don't use King David's
rating systems over here so that show
was definitely good for me multiple
personalities yeah just one kog and that
that's where I'm you and corporate C
there is there is Corporate corporate
there is Corporate Cog they get mad with
corporate Cog sometimes but it is what
it is but now look I thought it was um
kind of what king said as far as um
inroads continuing I love it I love I
love to see to me the difference is this
and I shout out to my man expat Arena
podcast this gu Co they invited me on
he's he's uh he lives in Japan he's
based out there he XBox guy he lives in
Japan I was on the show he was kind of
explaining to me how things are
perceived and he said in Japan it's all
about respect you come out there you go
into the home you're not live from a
zoom call you got Phil you got Sarah and
and to me the production value of the
show really resonated with me because I
like to see Japanese developers on an
Xbox stage speaking to in their native
tongue talking about what's going on
right and I forgot the chick um her name
is me misu misu I I like her which she's
been there before but you know her
authentic as far as you know speaking
the language someone from the from the
town so to speak you know what I'm
saying like I like that energy that
means you're serious you're in here
you're trying to approve she's an Xbox
influencer in Japan yeah like you you're
making the necessary steps to take this
serious you're not just doing lip
service and oh yeah you know bro like I
seen kajima and Phil they went to the
and and and um saraon they taking
pictures at the I'm calling it The
Shaolin Temple but whatever they was at
like they're they're really out there
like it it's it's a difference and I I
think you're seeing it now and I think
honestly did you did you see that um
Aaron kept running into Jeff mulle why
he running to Jeff in the forest in the
bamboo tree whatever they was at it was
hilarious it was absolutely hilarious
but I I like that energy so my rating of
the show I thought there was like I said
the King's Point a lot of stuff that was
missing the platform is on there I think
AC turning was good I like to see the A
Chronicles up there Square I predicted
would not do the Home Run just yet the
octopath felt last minute because they
ain't even have a trailer yet so I think
I agree I think that's business they
still have to ey out they can't talk
about that game pass thing yet or
whatever it is because it seems like it
was like yo let's make this happen um I
do think Final Fantasy you know is going
to come eventually after we talked maybe
the direct or whatever I mean after the
uh next uh showcase the Wong DLC looked
good I thought that was a big get get
from that to me the star was getting
like a dragon Ean and gayen in Game Pass
and have rgg say yo we know y'all want
infinite wealth with with Ichibon but yo
you this going to connect the story so
we putting this that was huge to have
that up in there Persona 3 tactica me
and adct played that at West that's my
joint they Atlas is outside they got the
c three they got all that stuff I'm I'm
feeling that um what was the other thing
now this is my only
negative my negative was the way they
was coming into this show chess was out
like yo y'all better tune in bro so this
is where I feel like they thought they
had a home run yeah and it ain't now
look they got to they got to to the
second base yeah like they thought they
like better cuz I think the swey and the
suda joint ain't hit Hotel Barcelona
yeah like they saved that for the yo one
more thing and in any circumstances you
got swey who's my man he makes the was
it the D the premonition whatever that
joint he also made a connect game for it
was like a detective that joint was fire
he a finished that but we going talk
about that but um what was it called
again I played that the first episode
with was like with the owl talking yeah
and the detective get yo swey he's weird
and I love it and it's fire but it's
just like all right cool no octopath was
a home run but J flame I see you but is
I don't consider it a home run it was
like that was a makeup that was a makeup
call for you know you supposed to do
something and salute to them for getting
that done last minute but the reason why
it's not a home run it didn't even you
could tell it was so last minut they
have a trailer they have no we don't
even know if it's gay pass but we know
it's gonna be G pass like you you could
tell they like yo we just got the deal
there we gotta give us something give us
something put it on the stage come on
all right cool so that didn't hit the
way I felt that one that was kind of the
Home Run was the the um the yakas stuff
but again Game Pass stuff but to me they
thought they had this they like yo we
gonna bring out swiy we gonna bring out
suda man me and them two make it it
would be like I don't know like Todd
Howard and someone else making a game
together right the the thought of it and
them some two together would be fire but
it was just something about the game I
just like I don't know if I'm there with
that right there you know what I'm
saying like I ain't I ain't I ain't feel
that verse that they were spitting so
you know we got to see I'm not saying
the game's going to be whack it just it
didn't look like an oh my God moment and
that's just where I'm at but other than
that it definitely fell short on the
just one more like yeah yeah there like
just one more and then I'm not going to
say pent energy but it was just not
there like we just like all right it's
cool I want to learn more about it this
little mash up but I if it would have
looked like
something I don't know if it would have
looked like what's kima's joint um death
stranding or something right you would
like oh look at this kind of thing it
just didn't have that look for me but
we'll see we'll see what other than that
solid show love that they're out there
cuz every year gets better and better
and that was pretty much pretty much and
not I love pent bit y'all come on I'm
just being funny y'all know what I mean
a lot of people even I got caught out
there think it was going to be a AAA oh
my God and then it was something you
know what they was doing it's like I
said man
like G gaming yeah I feel like right now
they and I've been the biggest like
person against Microsoft when it comes
to Japan and they shut me up a couple
months ago so like they the only thing
they really haven't done that I want
them to do is like maybe you know the
Mana games and Final Fantasy 7 remakes
but it's like you know I saw that octopi
travel to because I said last week or
the week before last I was like the
least thing I want is
traveler to and I'll be okay the most
thing is a seven remake uh Xbox title
facts yeah and they did that but that's
all I got we got one more in Sol any
super chats we got yeah we got super
chat we got Elan appeal don't fall
asleep on $5 Super Chat uh don't fall
asleep on Auden Chronicle 100 Heroes
announc that TGs coming to Game Pass oh
no no no we're not sleeping shout my man
Chris Jones that's his joint right there
yeah he love that cunit then we got
nintend taku2 Super Chat I'm still
boycotting swey for not finishing D4
that's what it was right D4 facts that
gay I love that gay he used connect in a
very unique way I agree yes I forgot
about that um that's it this the last
one this is you uh some virtual devices
outside what's going on oh yeah we got
Hardware announcement this past week uh
at The Meta connect event uh the Zak
came out it came out and announced the
meta Quest 3 or as our friends overseas
the Met
met meta The Meta is in
beta so uh yeah the meta Quest 3 was
announced uh launching in December for
uh $4.99 or 650 something like that or
something um obviously an improvement
over the meta quest one and two
um and and one of the the coolest things
that come out of it is that Xbox game
pass and their bid to reach two billion
Gamers is uh off to another platform and
will be arriving in December as well on
the meta Quest um with the ability for
you to play your all of your game pass
games on what
screen what you don't wait wait wait
wait wait you mean I ran out and I
brought this for no reason oh man
wait wait wait a second you said met
Quest hold up did that get shipped to
you who Shi that to I already know who
shipped that to you
wait we will not confirm or deny silence
on the set s silence on the I love I
love that King had that beside him for
he was waiting for this I went out and
purchased
this is on meta Quest 3 I I believe
believe that is correct sir all right
you going with Jim get out of here
actually the quest three I ain't G to
lie was s i i i i i watched that trailer
twice you Lord anti VR yeah yeah man
maybe I have to take the anti out of the
Lord wait wait wait wait hold after all
the slat I I got to hear about
what you I was just liking what I was
seeing they had like the the pass
through
thing cuz remember my big
issue with the headset is I I I don't
know what's going on in my surroundings
you know they kind of fix that to a
degree you know I apparently uh
apparently demo has that right
now did you see did you see the ass I
got it on PC oh it does it does it does
if you want it it's optional but it does
come I can do a wireless I don't need
anything Wireless oh and another thing I
forgot to mention about this special
about the meta Quest 3 it is not only a
VR headset it is also an AR headset wait
a second wait a second is this
PlayStation VR2 wait a second hold on no
play is it is PlayStation VR only so is
there any AR in this box no no no no no
mixed reality there I think I do think
that met over there you know they they
they got something they got something a
little bit better with this one I will
agree my only concern is like I got to
see the impelling G as the gamer part of
me but that Quest 3 trailer was picking
up more than the gamer part of me like
like the the YouTube thing where you can
watch YouTube videos anywhere and uh
they uh you know they they're eventually
wanting to go towards where you know
there's a lot of things that they took
from metaton realized okay this didn't
work this didn't work this didn't work
this didn't work let's uh let's fix what
we can and let's improve what we can and
I I that's why I'm like
I might I might try to try the quest
adct did you see the um Assassin's Creed
VR just yet yes I heard that
was I just I care about Deo too oh okay
I feel that I feel that de over here for
um for
mine yeah they do they do yes they do I
don't know I don't have I don't have how
much does the meta Quest 3 cost 500 cost
$499 sir
$499 for the 128 G model I believe and
then the 512 gab model if I could be
wrong about this so messy right now I'm
going to tell you right now how
much it's almost 700 if I'm not mistaken
it's almost
seven okay so but I can get in for
cheaper than for this hey so do I need
anything do I just purchase it and do I
need to buy like a PlayStation I
promised to chat he did not get that
just to do this okay he did not he did
not he did not don't listen to it
trying to figure out do I need anything
else to use it I think I think
that the meta and the quested enough
with the quest two to gauge my interest
a little bit with with the improvements
they made on the quest three yeah now to
be clear to be clear uh game pass on the
quest is cloud gamre is cloud streaming
it is not native correct but I'm sure
they does this thing have any Cloud
streaming it's no it's all Native
everything has to be downloaded to
PlayStation 5 poking I don't have the
option poking claims are call would have
to reconfirm but I think they took that
Facebook they took the Facebook account
uh uh requirement away yeah horiz you
don't need to link a Facebook account
anymore that was a project I worked on
yeah fantastic beautiful and everybody
wanted work on this
project the AR got a wire you ridiculous
so what do you guys yeah what do you
guys think of this I mean it's exciting
because again you know the the Xbox plan
right is to get on as many devices as
possible and to move Game Pass And to
clarify King we want King David's
opinion
not so the so the thing is I tried this
the the functionality you would use
basically to to play cloud gaming I did
it on the the PlayStation 4 because you
can play regular games right and it it's
like a 100 in screen or whatever
um I don't know what kind of
improvements to the tech there are it it
works fine on the PlayStation uh 5 and
the psvr2 but it is one of those things
like that screen is like you can you can
create obviously create distance from
your eyes so it's it'll be kind of far
away it's not on top of you but it gets
a little overwhelming for me after a
while so you know in theory the stuff is
really cool that you can do it I don't
know how often people going to be there
for hours playing you know their Xbox
games in in there but it is very cool
that it is there and it because it's on
this platform it opens up the
possibility for Xbox to finally make
some sort of inroads maybe inhouse in
terms of hey let's make some VR games
not because they've shown it's like hey
if with the ubiquity of the platform it
allows us to not have to invest in on
the hardware side on certain
things if we go into another platform
like a like a like a VR platform that
it's not something that we've that we've
gone into so it's very interesting
because it's going to be on every single
meta Quest going back to the first one
too it's not only just meta Quest 3 it's
going entire family of meta so now all
of a sudden you have potentially
millions of people that can throw their
game pass account on there and do that
so it gives you an incentive it's like
hey maybe we can create some VR
experiences that are Xbox VR experiences
so uh it really it it it's a it's a very
cool thing that may have further
implications that I think are are very
cool no doubt add any more further bars
or you got your bars off on this no I
just you know I definitely want to uh
you know congratulate meta because uh
they they they did The Impossible they
they they drew blood from a stone they
got you to be excited I'm like wow
because I I was looking I was like that
actually looks interesting like I
wouldn't say it's something I would play
on like on the regular but it's
something I would at least try they just
got to get more games like demio that
interest me that don't come to PC cuz
the moment that demio went on PC it it
was a
rat yeah no doubt no doubt Lord king um
new psvr2 owner and um see you making a
lot of comparisons over there but as far
as the meta Quest 3 is concerned what
are your thoughts about that and
obviously the Game Pass um partnership
or whatever well Game Pass for the win
of course I mean I mean come on like
everybody that's going to pick up a meta
Quest 3 if you have have a meta Quest
too I mean come on I mean stop hit me
with the commercial voice bro with the
come on come on come on guys I mean join
in N you can't be doing to join in son
y'all wanted Microsoft to compete uh
oh Microsoft don't have any VR Phil said
that he will make VR
well why buy the cow when you get the
milk for free like who the hell going to
go make Hardware oh Jim
did Jim out of here son he got us come
out he got
us youim got us come out he got us he
got us all so I'm assuming you you
prefer the the quest solution boy the
PS3 I saw dudes trying to uh Christopher
Hart out there well you know the
PlayStation has the eyeballs and
try he's trying to talk about the
feeling
box I'm like everybody's talking about
meta Quest 3 and I thought the
presentation was kind of white honest
with you I mean I saw the stuff it was a
lot of stuff there the games that was
there but you know they was talking
about the AR and VR is very hard sell to
people without the headset on them right
so you got to talk to them about
something else that's why VR is I mean
AR is so intriguing because AR is more
presentable yeah the public this is what
this would look like in this world right
opposed to doing VR so I think this is
why Facebook pivoted with uh meta they
could have doubled down and made a
stronger device that's in VR but with
the ability to do AR and a better VR
experience on a wireless headset that's
I think that's a little bit more
intriguing you heard adct talk about the
color pass through the color pass
through is available on this unit
because of the AR functionalities of
unit they need this color pass through
so it worked on somebody that doesn't
care about VR that's a good point that's
a good point he he he's DET tests
because a lot of people don't want that
complete closed off experience exactly
and the pass through on the place he has
four is not color it's not color it's
black and white black and white white I
mean but come on what did you expect all
right I mean stop acting like he gonna
give you premium he Ain doing that I
mean I'm listen I ain't capping anybody
that got
this this is the cheap boxes this is the
cheapest yeah the Box horrible ever seen
ever this is the worst cardboard they
had in the store and then this is how it
come nothing in there like that just
like that the console is thrown in there
and they like yo here you go not no
power your dreams not you want premium
packaging this this this is not it you
came for you didn't came for the
experience you came for the device you
got the device make it up out of here
we gave you your food shut up yeah yo
meta quest for the price point that they
have for the entry model and if you want
to do a little bit more an elite Factor
um it's a little bit
more still Wireless I think that talks
more to the casual than the hardcore you
still it's still cheaper than a
PlayStation VR no matter how you slice
it because you need a PlayStation 5 so
you must add that to the price you're
back to 1100 dummy I done told y' didn't
listen to me when I said it y was like
no King it's going to be X Y and Z
because I brought a PlayStation already
well let's say for the dude who don't
got a PlayStation and just wanted the VR
can't do that son you got a buck up and
you got to go buy that PlayStation 5 all
right so get in touch with your
neighborhood scalper and get yourself a
PlayStation 5 because that's where all
the PlayStation FES is at but again meta
Quest has a lot going on and then this
is the biggest thing this
dumb behind starts from
zero with the games your old games did
not carry over good point meta Library
plays with thousands of games from the
rip back comp back there all the stuff
that you you purchase it's available in
en's ecosystem and let's just say this
let's just say you don't have any games
but you have a Game Pass
subscription you log turn on your game
pass and you're playing games in VR
right there off the rip so your
thousands of games that you have from
your Xbox game pass is available facts
to you so I think it has a huge
Advantage from price point to
functionality to uh being tetherless and
to just brand awareness right because we
don't know what the hell going on with
this well we don't know what the hell we
don't know a lot of things this thing is
the most ambiguous piece of Hardware
that came out for it feels like a
passion project but we watched meta on
their passion project and I think it was
a little bit more clearer thank thank
you for your your glowing
recommendation um I can now talk about
this you know say obviously it's the
home team for me so disclaimer most of
you guys already know where where I'm at
but um look I was able to we internally
we call it dog fooding with name but
that's what we call it which is
basically testing the functionality so I
was being able to test game pass on
streaming on Quest 2 and Quest Pro and
now mind you I got the ideal setup you
know I got the gig up gig down the
internet is lit so what I went I said
I'm going to really test this thing I'm
going to do Halo infinite
multiplayer let's see where they at with
it right now the first thing I cannot
front barely any perceptible latency I
was super impressed I was able to do
full batches so again you get your
controller syn it to the your Xbox
controller you sink it to the device so
theoretically I'm with my own projection
screen then the thing that's ill King is
that I could stretch this AR
style anywhere in my living room I'm
literally making myself a movie theater
and extending the screen in my house
playing game pass it that was the CH
it's basically another screen it was
like I just bought a projection joint
and it looked the clarity looked good
now mind you this is the old Tech this
is all Quest 2 Quest Pro this is not on
Quest three the latest tech I have not
played the latest version of this so
there's a strong chance this is even
going to improve so I thought that part
was was cool we already know how that
synergizes with Xbox's strategy because
we've already seen they're making that
controller what is it cble yeah with all
these different connection direct to
Cloud Bluetooth so it fits Microsoft's
Vision as well right so so question yeah
what's up so when you stretched out the
screen right was it in AR so you had
your your full view of your living room
and everything or was it you were in an
environment I was in an environment I
was in an environment it was still
closed it wasn't AR it was closed off
but the ability to have to manipulate I
was using it in like what they call your
um your home base so to speak like your
home yeah kind of thing but the fact
that I could make it smaller I can make
it bigger I can that was key for me cuz
that felt like yo this is a different
thing I have my own you know 80 in if I
want to make it you
type you know screen type situation so
that that part was really impressive and
um yeah I thought that was cool as far
as like adct talk about the colorback
pass through is a game changer I've been
playing with that on Pro a pro so it's
even more improved now with with Quest 3
again you just do your TAP you're still
in around and and to what adct is saying
is when when we play demo again closed
off I'm playing on psvr2 or you play
closed off there is a difference when
you are using AR and I am stretching the
board placing it in my dining room table
on my couch moving it making it as big
as I want small as I want and then I'm
have my whole living room surrounded my
couches I could see everything so I'm
put it you know what it reminds me King
it reminds me of how the old Hollow lens
demo when they had the Minecraft was
supposed to be then the thing with the
demo is they're utilizing Tech which
makes you like recognize the objects in
your house so for example if the it
recognize your couch all that stuff if
the dice rolls over it's going to bounce
off the couch and then go down it's
treating like that these are real
objects in the space when you scan them
then the other thing that's lit is
augments so augments is you making
implementing like these custom virtual
objects and then putting them into your
play Space so for example like they had
like a um there was like a a wall like a
like a like a a a picture of Port that I
could hang up put it into my space and
then whenever I want to you know use it
to play that game or put up a Mir like
it's it's basically putting like real
objects in space it's hard to describe
it's like that nft world that they made
that they were really going heavy in
remember it was supposed to be like my
home or something like that yeah NS
lived in that home very very very
impressive and um look you know they
they went with the pancake the the P the
pixel count is insane the resolution the
lighting I highly advise people to um
play Red matter 2 red matter 2 is this
kind of like space game that really
showcase the power of of and you can see
between Quest 2 and the quest three the
difference it's it's not even close
Assassin's Creed look looks really cool
they had the the parkour they doing it
they doing it like not like a full overw
world they're doing it like stages so
one you can play through the Ezio era
one you can play through the Cassandra
era like they doing it like that and um
the thing that was bro you do the joint
you got the hidden blades you got the
leap of faith when you do the joint off
the thing I thought I was like okay all
right you know what I'm saying but the
the key is what you said K you know the
back cup pack is huge because not only
there going to be 50 between now and
launch I mean by the end of the year
they're going to have 50 new games that
are Quest three then they're going to
have 50 games that they're going to
patch for Quest three enhancements for
the end of this year so that's 100 games
that's going to be Quest three ready
between Now launch and in the end of the
year just just this year so the
commitment to games was there which was
which was key you so I thought that was
cool um they go with the hand tracking
if you don't if you don't want to use
the control and stuff like that and then
I think the last thing um what is it
October 10th um they've giving you
asgard's rft too which looks phenomenal
and that's going to be AE so basically a
free packing AAA experience game when
you pick it up so look I thought it was
um very very impressive October 10th
I'll be there you know what I'm saying
and uh come check us out man but yeah
and Demo's got stuff cooking they got
demo battles you know how I feel about
demo resolution games stuff like that
but it look look look I think the
correct approach for adct to say what he
said really resonated which is going
with the AR and then going with the AI
stuff that they got cooking as well so I
think that is as a to get more of the
Casual instead of the person with the
you know closed off hardcore exp and and
if you want that you can still connect
to your PC do your halflife Alex you can
do all that stuff you're not limited you
have the option so good show on B them
and like I said good we'll we'll see but
um K you get one for free k comment but
look at the end of the day but I will I
will say The Game Pass thing was impr I
put it through its Paces bro Halo
infinite multiplayer match who did that
for
you sa young Odin actually was young
Odin dominous Max a really expensive did
that quarterback I talk about the GM
thank you so much you're ridic anyways
okay that's all I got s you wouldn't get
the uh super chats for ad pass out cuz
he going pass out I going through it
over there we
got cullin Prime $5 Super Chat meta
Quest 3 releases this month and Game
Pass in December yes yes oh sorry yes so
the actually the headset releases before
the game pass they're just making sure
the Kinks is out of it but is Game Pass
going on that service oh oh or they
going to launch the service on
everything I'm just saying though man
keep ridiculous you're ridiculous then
we got Hollywood rule 55000 you know the
new the new PlayStation head might be
amenable the game pass on Playstation
never know you never know you never know
we might we might have a Spider-Man
situation on Yo K give me the link for
that 20% off y'all
whing there we got Zuck is not giving
you no discounts out
here there we got Hollywood rules $5
Super Chat happy Sunday my video game
cousins on vacation with the lady
outside the state still wanted to
support my boys King something happened
at Sony question question question
blessing yeah man that guy gone man like
I
said there we got Spartan 6615 Super
Chat the evolution of gaming is on the
horizon Phil Spencer is at the lead of
the
charge he's the last man
standing he's literally wiped the board
of all his contemporaries he's the last
man stand y'all got to find new faces
like y'all actually got a villain over
to run Nintendo you got
Bowser y y' went out and got Mario's
Arch
Enemy just Ste down field cuz Reggie
said no I'm out of here mess this it is
the best my CEO is still here man let's
get it Bessie trying to get a generation
then we got uh we got Bruno Ramos Diaz
with the uh 279
90 uh African rans oh wow wow thank you
but very generous wow love this podcast
hate The Next Gen X boxes but I will
hold the line listen you can just go
ahead go on to NZXT get yourself a play
get yourself a player three AMD Edition
good to
go the link is in the
description you will actually get you
some money off of that Xbox said no
console required all you need is console
requ Hey Hey Hey man hey man you're not
about that hybrid future don't worry
about it just just get yourself the AMD
player three edition if you want to play
at the highest Fidelity man let's go get
it let's get uh that's said we Rec all
right no doubt now this is the phone
from last week obviously it's a little
older but we had to get it off with the
preliminary approval of by the CMA over
the Xbox ABK deal what do you think has
the biggest impact to the Xbox ecosystem
once approved the choices are a infusion
of the ABK catalog into cons so Game
Pass B marketing rights for Call of Duty
to the Casual Gamer C PC game pass and
mobile growth or D I don't care if we
don't get those damn Transformer catron
games and Game Pass we fin the riot go
check that hit it when it goes up Salute
to the realm everybody that pulled up a
thousand of y'all hit that like button
we having some fun Lord adct look I Ste
the away I was going to give him his
outro where can find people find you we
guess get him on me on Twitter at Lord
addict
IOP I apologize for being in and out
some stuff's going on and I have some
minor tooth pain too oh I'm sorry yeah
you seem my God but you know pretty good
show we had to over a thousand like
11,00 some people in there putting like
roll running away with the narrative on
the Cyber Punk thing I am not saying
screw the game I'm saying that when it
comes to games in the condition it was
at launch to now it's a it's a white and
gray area on whether or not a sport
that's all I was saying I mean he's
literally playing the game so and don't
worry they was coming for me he like kog
is defending I'm like I'm just listening
to my man I I agree with what he said I
can't believe kog is Corporate cing
Shilling I'm like yo Somebody went in on
me son I was like damn I'm just trying
to help explain what my B position was I
would never know if it's not in color I
ain't here oh man no doubt but cor car
heard put it in that's the
word no doubt anyway no doubt and Lord s
wa can find people find you what you got
going on Sir uh hopefully doing more
gaming this week than this past week
we'll we'll see how that
goes no doubt and hopefully not coughing
next week um poking claims yes you can
use quest uh on Steam games yes you
connect your what you call it oh yeah
100% that's how I that's how I play Half
Life Alex half life Alex baby you can do
and you get more Fidelity if you again
if you have XT rig perfect with
VR perfect with VR hey you want to you
want to Max it out you know what I'm
saying I I haven't I haven't played it
on the new rig I I played it I played
can I hook up um can I hook up my
PlayStation to you can
try I will say one thing when I launched
that Starfield on this thing
man Chef kiss power that's right show us
the build that that's the way power
Nintendo hey he did say step your PC
game up right so we
did we just listen to NT we able to step
up that PC game facts use the link in
the get out of here DJ with that Xbox
podcast talking about
PC ain't nothing wrong with my
Bild we we we are everything show and
what's funny is I'm playing cyber Punk
on both PC and Xbox thank you salute no
doubt go get stop skipping leg day oh
you good anything else I'm good I'm good
Lord King the messiest of all messy we
know it was coming today we a going to
find people find you what you got going
on besides follow me on Twitter yes at
uh King David OTW because y'all probably
be putting in Lord King David I can't
find him this other dude keep popping up
King David OTW and that does not stand
for on the way so don't don't play with
me bro but um yeah you can find me on
Twitter unlike Jim damn wow messy I'll
be around next fiscal
period yo Jim I tried to support I heard
you was leaving I went and picked up um
the PlayStation VR as a you know
collector's
item you was out there you Boogie out
with the with the passion project I
appreciate you Boogie out I'm gonna get
your uh your portal too I heard that's
the last situation the last situation
listen I'm trying to you know like these
Collective these are relics that are
going to go out of style this is
memorabilia you know oh my Lord when
they come to your house and they be like
Papa what's
that what what what is this
thing oh that's a PlayStation 5 it's the
last time yo you stupid yeah it it was
the most unstable console of its
generation it's a juggler son Pap what
is that I cannot with him I'm G to stay
messy I hope you do like it I told you
he was out of there who did that for you
Phil dominis Maximus sper and he did it
all
Natty wow this guy here man this guy
here knew it was coming we knew it was
coming but anyway shout out to s for for
providing some balance to help me out
with savagery oh look again everybody
again appreciate the support was a ton
of y'all up in here a lot of fun stuff
cooking up you already know again
everybody thank you for the love last
week and again yo go support we got a
lot of stuff that we got getting behind
and we got some more future stuff going
on anything for anybody else before we
get out of here adct anybody else we
good we are good everybody look enjoy
your Sunday we out up yeah try to figure
out who we would send them to yeah who
we sending them what we doing all right
I let I'll let you guys decide I'll give
you guys a name and I'll let you guys
decide who we send them to and then go
go to f go fund me yeah go to F go f go
fundme no doubt no doubt everybody enjoy
your right oh I'm wait I'm wait I'm wait
until you sit right now wait until you
sent no doubt all right
so game we can send uh we'll send you
back to back man we'll send you back
back there back for that I'm Len you
guys over there definitely go over there
show some love if you even if you can't
chill for a minute go in there drop an I
raid drop him a like no doubt everybody
catch you guys later enjoy your
next week
[Music]
peace